day one of the st
louis rapid and blitz played online for
the very first time
ten of the world's top players brought
their virtual a-game center stage
to try to win one of the last
tournaments of a thrilling summer season
round two saw a shocking disconnect that
caused world champion magnus carlson
to lose against yanipanichi and that
left the door open to levon aronian and
pitala harry krishna
to surge into a two-way tie for first
the intense fighting continues an
exciting rapid pace day two of non-stop
action
coming up next
hello everyone and welcome back to the
saint louis
rapping and blitz i'm jennifer shahady
and i'm here with grandmasters yasser
sarwan
and maurice ashley to call day two of
this thrillfest
hey yes maurice what's up hello jennifer
hello maurice it's a pleasure as always
to be with you both calling all the
action hello everyone
uh welcome to the show and thank you for
joining us and sharing your day well day
one was a game of thrills and spills but
also
connections pentala hari krishna
went to the home of david navarra
because his connection was stronger
something that
maybe world champion magnus carlson
regrets that
he didn't do as he disconnected and lost
allowing the former mentioned hari krash
hari krishna to share first maurice
quite an eventful day one
it was indeed eventful you talked about
that disconnect that's big
we really don't like seeing that happen
of course in the age we live in
it does and it's not even the world
champion
who is immune to this happening uh of
course now
levon aronian and pitala harry krishna
share first place
even if magnus if you think about it had
drawn that game he still would have been
in first these two players
are playing excellent chess and we'll
see whether or not they can keep it up
well let's take a look at all the
standings jen yeah well here they are
guys
indeed we have these two great players
at the top of the leaderboard lavonna
ronian
ventala hari krishna both with five
points two wins and a draw yesterday
wesley so and yeah no pomochi also doing
well
with four points magnus carlsen right
there with an even score but a very sour
taste
from that round to debacle absolutely
and our schedule for today jeff
the schedule is three rounds a day in
the rapid portion
um and they start every hour and 15
minutes
so we'll have three of those today three
more tomorrow that'll close out the
rapid portion but
don't forget this is a combined sport
tournament we are not two separate
tournaments
so you'll carry over your score from the
rapid and go into blitz
um which will close out this thrilling
event and
that brings us to our format which is
indeed
going to show you why these rapid games
are so important
well they're double weighted so two
points at stake for each rapid game
those of you who are watching the 960
along with tournament co-leader harry
krishna
who said he had our his eyes peeled
through our commentaries so
big thank you to him um this time
control is a little bit different
game 25 with a five second increment
whereas in the 960 event
we played a game 20 with a 10 second
increment
and uh the leaders it looks like they're
gonna do some clashing
maurice take us through our most of the
time this is where you want to get those
points and so it's critical
every single day and this day too is
going to be even more critical
as we see some dramatic clashes right
out the gate
let's begin with one of our leaders
lavon
aronian lavon with a
great start he did have a lucky hiccup
game we have to mention against
christchurch where he was completely
busted but managed somehow to survive
that and even turn the tables well
boy he'd better look to survive this
first opponent he has
one magnus carlsen who will be looking
to knock him off his perch and then
he'll play his co-leader pentalary
krishna
in round five before closing out the day
with the youngster
jeffrey jean and we know that
hari krishna he's playing lavon in the
middle round
uh who does he play however to start the
day
it will be one yanipanichi and he'll
close it out with
magnus carlsen that's not two gangsters
you want to have to face especially
given that he's gonna have to play levon
oronian
in round five what a lineup he can pick
him in the ardor
then that will he be able to maintain
his lead
given this murderer's role that he will
have to face
and of course the one person who
is in both draws is magnus
carlsen and we've got to pay attention
to him we've already mentioned he is
playing lavon in round four and fintala
in round six in round five he'll be
playing against
america's lanier dominguez magnus
had that bad game well it was just a
disconnect
it looked like the position was more or
less drawn so
he would have gotten one point not two
and that's why we say he
wouldn't be in the lead right now even
if he didn't
didn't disconnect but still he wouldn't
be a full point behind a full two points
behind
the leaders will he be able to turn
things around today
his destiny in his own hands that's
where he likes it
to be able to beat the guys who he needs
to
so this would be a big deal a little bit
of a smile on his face right now he
seems incredibly relaxed
at the moment uh that doesn't really
bode well guys
for the rest of the field absolutely
speaking of the rest of the field gem
let's take a look at the pairings for
round four
that's here they are um magnus against
levon
and harry christian version obviously
two games that we'll have
our eyes peeled on but there's lots of
fun pairings here i mean
i'm really looking forward to um blitz
legends alexander grishok and
nakamura facing off against the teams
the teams
played so well in their head-to-head
battle yesterday i gotta tell you i was
just like
i was uh just so um enthralled by the
level of play they were
executing in a one minute game with a
five second increment granted
um so it'll be interesting to see what
they bring to these
incredible blitz players today this is
rapid not blitz they'll get a chance to
play actual blitz
twice against everyone in the field as
well but
you know the thing about rapid is if
it's an interesting game in a rich
opening it ends up turning into some
kind of blitz battle in
most of the games for sure and
uh jen what are they playing for big
bucks here at stake at the sinking with
rapid and blitz being shout out to the
saint louis jazz club
and to the stingfield dr genie and rex
singfield for making this possible 250
000 in total prizes including 60k
for first you know it is a difficult
time for many people
um all over the world and so it's really
nice to see
the the sponsorship and the support of
chess
persist through these times
extraordinary
very very nice indeed oh
wow very exciting time you're now going
to
announce our i'm hearing from producers
this is
this is our we're on the spot now um now
that uh
you know magnus is not in the lead we're
not all gonna be madness right
um but we have to keep our picks for
the winner of the tournament and i
picked lavonna ronian
hikaru
and we see all the pics on the screen
and of course i
picked magnus carlson uh we picked all
these picked after
day one by the way so this was before
during rehearsal
that we had the chance to do this and so
uh
you know jen you waited until lavon was
in first place
i think i picked him last time he won
the saint louis raven and woods
really okay yeah it doesn't get a lot of
attention when i pick it right
like forget about it i know the feeling
oh please yes sir you send the players
when you win
you get the planes that fly with the
banners you know like
advertising banners and yeah iran won
this
time jen is more quiet about it
you know i i can't say that i i don't
brag a little bit
when i get it right but uh yeah yeah sir
you definitely uh you definitely make it
well known
just before they get underway the
disconnection
in the forfeit i went to the chess-based
website and i was reading some comments
and is it too severe
shouldn't there be something like you
know you've got five
minutes to reconnect is it too severe
to get the big fat zero for a
disconnection and you can
and if you only had 30 seconds left uh
discuss what do you guys think i think
the problem is i was thinking about this
myself i think it's actually a pretty
complicated question
like in poker you have something kind of
similar to that where you do have like a
time bank
that protects you a little bit
especially if you haven't used much of
it
um if you have a disconnect with your
internet so you won't fold your hand
until that's
empty the problem with carrying that
over to chess is that
i mean not that any of these players
would ever do this but
even inadvertently what if they happen
to disconnect in a position that's
really really rich
and is a position where they actually
need three minutes to kind of solve the
right
move even if it was just coincidental
and obviously these players could play
really well blindfold
that would be a very unfortunate
situation if they could you know use
that to their advantage so i think
that's why it's trickier in chess than
in poker
i think said potential abuse is what
you're
worried about yeah or even in even in a
bird interview
even unintentional yeah that's right
okay give me
give give these guys a few more minutes
and they'll work it all out you know all
the
variations so it is a challenge it's
really unfortunate it's sad
nobody wants to see it happen it's it's
never good when it happens let's put it
that way it just
there's there's no good way for that to
be resolved
and it's what it is we're we're living
with it right now
so but you're right games that doesn't
mean it can't be improved i mean we
could still
talk talk about that for a long time and
maybe in one of the breaks will continue
but the games are underway and
yes is playing the grundfeld well
surprise surprise
right and magnus who's actually been
really uh shaking the world on the white
side of the grunfeld
i mean he's defeated such players as
grishock
and nepo really convincingly mvl
also very convincingly on the white side
a little bit surprised
by the queen b3 choice we've actually
been seeing some captures on d5
and h2 h4 and in fact lavon's been
leading the charge
but there they are in uh one of the
sharpest uh lines of the grunfeld this
move a7
a6 there's knight a7
knight d7 um there's just so many ways
of treating the position the move a7
a6 uh it's one of the shadows
yeah one of many like solid choices here
is and i i
can't remember who what it was but i
feel like i saw somebody
tweet recently that it's interesting
that this line used to be you know
considered one of the most dangerous
but um in recent years it's not as
popular because people
had discovered that almost every
sub-variation for black was pretty
decent there you go
this move e5 okay that's a real
challenge
now in the old days they didn't like
this move e5
so much preferring moves like bishop e3
and
and other choices on this the the
problem
with e5 is uh that there's this
queen sacrifice line bishop e6 and i
know that this
was back in the day uh very very very
topical eventually they kind of said
nah the three pieces for queen and pond
just weren't
giving white enough of an advantage so
they stopped playing
e5 so they thought white was was only a
little bit better there because
they thought it was even yeah at first
glance i would i would think that you
know white would have
a really nice game there just because
you know we've been taught
that the three pieces if they're
decently well anchored
um are usually just really really
dangerous against the queen
but um somehow especially since after we
castle we're gonna have
an uber safe king right right uh
what was it that gave black that i think
it was c5
yeah if memory serves you take
queen comes out you castle like you say
your king is really safe
but okay um there's a chopping block and
the
three minor pieces don't really
well i mean you can always get into
tempo of course for development
uh this was where it went but let's see
no
uh he didn't yeah b5 on the board
yeah he played b5 instead and now if
bishop e6
now how does it change things if black
plays bishop b6 in this position
exactly well probably um
a great deal of similarity in fact that
the key difference that i can see is
that
obviously the bishop is um
not on b3 it's undeveloped and
although there's some pressure down the
a file bishop takes
b5 on tap so bishop e6 i think is a real
valid move
again levon shied away from that line
he's played
knight g4 by the way
by the way guys i know this one this one
is rich but we've got to see the opening
fireworks from what looked like a fairly
tepid position in the other key match-up
between pinta lahari krishna who is
typhoon first and yan
the pomnicci who is right behind him you
look at this formation
it's important to see as you look at
this position
go back to look at the opening move
forward queen takes d4
in the the open sicilian
not known to produce too many fireworks
and look at the next couple of moves
knight f6
whoa exactly he said whoa bishop e2 you
go what's
that about knight c6 prompting the queen
to drop back
g6 castles bishop g7 and then h3
another slow move by white and
bam with black d5 gets thrown
into the mix the guy hasn't developed
any pieces on the queen side no night
out no bishop out
so d5 said nipple said let me go for it
why not make this break in the center
and after a capture knight takes d5
queen b3 the rook d1 threat
is on top so he played his knight back
to b6
rook to d1 anyway hitting the queen
then after queen c7 knight to c3 with
the threat of knight to b5
black dare not castle because knight b5
is coming
with tempo and it may embarrass his
queen so instead he played
bishop e6 look at these sharp moves
remember how quiet the game started
it's like attack attack go go go your
queen or mine and
hey you attacked my queen knight b5 let
me attack
yours queen back to b8
and now the expected move might have
been c4 there but there was a knight a5
shot that he had to worry about so he
played queen to a3
and castles gets played and now we're in
this position
wow so much happened guys so many
threats
especially to the queen to the queens on
top of it
in the early going of this game yeah it
seems like there was a lot of gnashing
of teeth
a great big clash but at the end of it
all
what are we looking at we're looking at
still a little bit
tame position knight d4 okay
tickling at the bishop but more
importantly saying
queen takes e7 if you trade
at the end of that trade there's two
there's a double threat if you will uh
the threat to take on e6 as well as e7
so this move knight d4 kind of puts a
little
oh okay e2 is hanging e2 is hanging so
maybe maybe it's a little bit awkward to
try to grab that pawn on e7
uh if rook e8 uh obscures the bishop
whoops so maybe it's not as dangerous
for
nepo as at first i thought knight d4
bishop d5
and you can't really capture the e7 pawn
knight d4 on the board sorry
uh strange opening though right maurice
queen d4
bishop e2 queen e3
and h3 as well
it's very fascinating that you could
play this quietly i would have just
thought
nada for for uh white in that position
and maybe he still has nothing here i
think
i heard that knight c3 we're hearing
from the from our producer that knight
c3 was the novelty
in this position which seems like the
most natural move on the board i'm even
surprised
knight c3 i think knight c3 novelty i'm
with you 100
if that's not the most uh natural move
in the position i don't know what else
is more natural than
uh developing and and
waiting to produce a threat but okay
keep an eye on that uh we'll just
sorry should we just take a quick gander
around the horn we've got yes
i wanted to jump to that game with
icarusa because the current position
they have
you see the the the double pawns on
the d line and then you look over and
you say
what's up with black's pawn structure i
mean we might be
looking at where like the weirdest
opening pawn structure
you could guess that the double d-pawns
but in the meantime black's pawn on e7
is fully backward on an open file and
the pawn on
g7 is also backward but
not an open file at the moment
whose pawn structure is worse i mean
well let's see how they got here again
it was a karo khan i guess hikaru's
tipped his hand that he likes to play
this h4 line
that he did play against magnus in round
one uh
that was a big setback of course for
hikaru's chances
and they quickly continued
with the line i think uh in the previous
game
it was e6 bishop g5
queen a5 that that game between magnus
and hicaro in this game uh
immediately queen a5 a6 okay
e6 and this is how we got the double d
pawns and the knight set up this
beautiful square f5
castles is apparently this has been
played before but the castle's move
is the novelty and again if you ask me
that looks like a really natural move
as well you want to bring your rook to
the e-file get your kick out of dodge
um well uh
a lot of ugly ugly squares ugly
weaknesses but
at the moment again i'm a big french fan
so the knight on f5 really gets uh
i like that so for example maurice if i
were to play the move
g6 here would you
want to jump to e5 or g5 or just chill
what i want to do is play 95. you're
asking me what i want to do yeah my
problem is the d-pawn
hangs after you move the piece exactly
and so
i have to justify why i moved the knight
just to get this
generalized attack on it so i'd have to
be a bit more restrained
and probably just wait to see where
things are going
right leave the night on the square then
the next real issue is the night on b1 i
don't really
want to be on c3 not long term you're
bringing the piece out
it's got to be somewhere else and so
you're making this point as you should
going to different squares on the king
side what would be the ideal square
c3 e2 f4 h3 to g5
that's a lot of a big journey for a
knight to spend all that time
uh just to get to those queries now
critical to note
is that certainly the plan for black
is to get a bishop to g7 and make you
defend
your pawn on d4 so we have to anticipate
this attack as it's going to happen in
the game as well he's going to play
knight d7 and bishop g7
so that's going to be some good coverage
so we need to we need to be ready for
that
without anything uh in my opinion
we do see two moves rookie one rook g8
rook
e1 have been played the movie brooke g8
is curious to be sure sorry
uh castles rook g8
is that what we would call a mysterious
rook move
yeah definitely uh what that
that one that one certainly qualifies
because no g5 is gonna happen
anytime soon with three things guarding
that
that's pawn maybe he realized his pawn
was backward and he decided to support
it
i mean this just does not this does
nothing to do with that
and now he's dropped his king back to e8
even
after after it oh i just have to look at
you on
huh yeah
wow well these last two moves have
really thrown me for a loop
because i was i was just gonna say that
like uh aesthetically i love the
position for white
even though it was challenging um i
it just seemed like a lot easier to play
for white and well
um you know because your your correct
moves are like what rookie one
and knight c3 and knight e2 it's kind of
like the first things you would think of
but
clearly for um you know such a strong
player to you know
think that rook g8 and king eight are
the best moves either this position is
bad for black or it's hard to play
like one of those things is definitely
true maybe both
i want to put the knight on f4 the white
knight now really looks like it belongs
on f4
because from f4 there's there's an e6
point as well
that's going to be just absolutely
fantastic i might even sacrifice my
d-pawn just
to make that happen uh maybe i'm being a
bit premature here
knight f4 uh bishop takes d4
does allow knight e6 and the bishop
drops back to b6 but this is where i
would think
the initiative would start kicking in
potentially do i get an a4 move for
example
just just to harass you and
bring all the other pieces into the game
very quickly as well
it just looks like it's it's probably
worth a pawn here to make you suffer
in this kind of position of bishop to g5
remember black can't castle
so yeah where's the king going to go i
mean it just looks so dynamic for him
i'm still i'm i'm really for me i'm
still puzzling over the move rook g8
let's just check in on wesley cell and
lanier
and that is a very theoretical uh
variation of the open spanish that the
two players are playing they're still in
the
in theory a quick check in on jeffrey
and grisham well this is strange it
looks like a
closed sicilian except this bishop on e2
isn't on g2
which is common in the closest so you
what just happened bishop
b5 czech sicilian with 97 yeah
i said no you're you're wondering like
why is the bishop 22 and a bishop behind
texas
right right right right precisely so
and we've caught up with the players so
i'm supposing that queen takes b2 would
really
be egregiously foul uh
you could end up getting oh you're
you're knight oh sorry you're not
your pawns on d3 indeed i'm so used to
open uh
sorry um maybe okay so knight
rook b1 and queen c3 rook b7
this is not like winning right i mean
black has an extra pawn
this is great for black i mean the
bishop on e2 isn't
unless i can ensnare your queen somehow
but it looks like you might be escaping
the e5
right uh sorry if i play a move like
night
night after work b7 or v8 i might have
like a knight b1 type move
i'm sorry so rook takes b7 you have a
uh knight b1 type of an f4 i'm just
trying to like
yeah you can just take on e1 exactly
yeah
okay that that looks like a challenge
for sasha and he's looking at that
b-pawn
he's taking it yeah he's taking it pawn
captured and rugby one queen takes on c3
have been played well this one is
interesting
but take a look at our marquee game
you're going to like this position
between look at what lavonne has allowed
at the time i don't like it
i don't like it i just picked lavon to
win the event
i mean whoa he played back
a couple of moves before as you go there
bishop e6
letting d5 just come with tempo
just straighten your face d5 and you
play knight to d7
so this is the idea pawn takes e6 you
have knight c5
yes or king queen and bishop yeah indeed
but
magnus has now dropped the bishop all
the way back to b1
bishop to b1 getting the bishop out of
the way
out of harlem square not fair i
sacrificed 26. you're supposed to take
it
exactly too bad chess is not checkers
but that
this one here is is looking
very scary with that those two pawns
in the position but can black drum up
some play
i don't really see how they well we
better move our bishop
so okay so the problem is if we
if we tickle the queen the queen returns
the favor
and uh black's feelings are getting hurt
two pieces on pre but the problem with
bishop f5
is we can take and if you take on b1 we
take on g7
and that's not good
so we have to in fact recapture on h6
but then our king side
or me i beg your pardon uh the
the kingside pawn shelter well
that looks like what pawnshop
it's not the best shield yeah when you
decide to play the grunfeld this is
usually not the position you're after
your opponent's got pawns on d5 and e5
yeah
and the way they did it by the way you
know we learned from the old days we're
going back to the
late 1800s mid to late 1800s
the whole reason and you'll show this as
a in a beginner's class
you're trying to control the center of
the board right and the reason why you
want to
is because if you don't put some pawns
in the center the other guy will start
pushing pawns in the center of the board
and guy or gal pawn to e5
pawn to defense we've seen steinitz win
these kind of games morphy when these
kinds of games they take a rook off the
board
and win these kinds of games in the in
the classical days
here you see the pawn went to e5 and
chased the knight
then h3 and the knight ended up on eight
six now opponent went to d5 to chase the
bishop
you're thinking how is he allowing this
stuff sinus would just be rolling over
and it's great
how can you play chess like this and get
away with it and i'm not sure
you can get away with it as you look at
the board now
vaughn seeing bishop b1 land on the
board
two pawns standing abreast on the fifth
rank
the bishop he must be wondering about
knight c5 because he doesn't want to
play bishop f5
precisely because of the line you just
showed yes but knight c5
is clearly not possible he's going to
drop material
so what else can he be thinking about is
there another like
move that's an alternative here
i don't see anything else to do myself
either i mean i'm looking at some
desperados uh but they look
terrible desperate yeah i've been really
desperate
uh you know jan heinder very cynically
he would look at a position like this
and he would say um modern chess you
know
like what is black done you know i mean
because the classical guy is yeah you
want to give me the center thank you
i'll take the center oh you want me to
occupy the center and attack your pieces
with a gain of tempo
i'll do that too so yeah i mean magnus
is just
very forceful and guess what there was
in fact no choice for lavonne
he did play into this line that
had you cringing at jen you're
you're about to say this is not why you
played the grunfeld
uh to get an exposed king and
you know you you're supposed to be
countering white
center right with moves like c5 and your
bishop on g7 and
you don't have any i
you know lavonne missed something with
maybe
knight c5 queen a3 like maybe he was
analyzing knight c5 queen d1 or
there had to be something because i
don't think that was the position he was
after
i think it might have been just that the
bishop b won retreat
just not because that's not that's not a
a retreat that you expect right you kind
of think
okay yeah the guy's going to do
something to stop me from playing knight
c5 maybe yeah
his queen maybe but bishop b1
uh is very very strong a little bit
surprising and then when you look at it
just
like for another 30 seconds or so and it
hits you
oh my goodness this is a really really
good position for white
this is just very this is just terrible
i i know jen you
you know you tell your students to play
the grunfeld
and now they're like what i'm not
playing that one
well rick stingfield plays the green
found he like he
likes that opening i mean so many of the
players that we invite on the grand
chess tour are specialties in this
opening
spidler maxine bashir the grav
um they all get in and all of them get
in there and occasionally played in room
field but
jeffrey zhang but today is not the
grunfeld's finest day i'll tell you
well is lavon ever a greenfield player
do we know if levon is a grenfell player
yeah he he he has it
definitely in his repertoire and he
likes playing both sides i mean
but uh i'm sure he's not signed up for
this position this
i mean it's gone really really south
quick check on our other
uh co-leader wow uh
okay sparks are flying over here guys
between
uh uh hari and jan
we left it we just saw the move knight
d4
bishop d5 which was kind of expected oh
bishop e3
e6 looks right
bishop takes f 3
not even waiting for c4 how about that
bishop giving up the two bishops just
like that
wow okay well
this is a monster bishop i mean look at
that
that's really really nice and by the way
i felt that way about the position when
the queen went to b8
that that was the only eyesore for black
that needed to be solved
at some point when you saw it happen the
moment it happened he said okay
his only discoordination issue is this
queen
if he could castle if the queen had a
straightforward square
then all his pieces just fly into the
game right his castle you bring your
rooks to the
open files and you're feeling like it's
a decent position
this was a problem to solve but the way
the game transpired the way
harry started making specific moves
let's hit the bishop on d5
let's make it move and then he puts
these make these couple of moves as well
and now he gets to play a move like
bishop d6
queen's still in the corner and then he
anchors that pieces you call it jazz a
monster piece
that bishop just looks really strong is
it just biting on granite at the moment
we'll see uh as this move 93 forked
pieces and force him to
concede a bishop yeah i was about to say
this knight d3 that
wait wait a minute that's uninvited it
was rook d1
uh rook d1e1 best because after this
um i'm jury's
out there's there's play something the
potential
for play in a black's position night
excuse me
uh miss the fact that this little
charmer
is on pre
nepal looking pretty okay suddenly
i that pawn on d3 is very disconcerting
uh rook d4 gains a tempo
so that you could play rook and double
dub oops excuse me that was not the
intention just trying to clear the board
but i'm thinking rook d4
here and uh time
that the the uh jan has
an extra six minutes on the clock well
john has a time advantages
yes i can't remember the last time that
happened
oftentimes he's like double or triple
his opponent because he just
plays so quickly in the opening right
exactly so again a quick check on magnus
wait what did you really see e7 e6 what
castles e6 can i just
when you had a golf ball or my butt
are my eyes deceiving me here you mean
just take 26
and then and then you got to play knight
c5 you can't even catch
right right in between move right
that's just that's the old squishy and
now where does my queen go
c2 d5
this is simply excellent for white i
i why
you're at a loss for words which is rare
for yes
zero on rare for any of us but
i like going something nice to say about
lebron's position
i don't see it i don't know what it is
that i'm supposed to say that's so nice
it's really not it's not pretty uh
queen a3 queen d5 queen c2 all look
like white sky just
snacking a very very happy pawn speaking
of snacking very happy pawns when we
left it
sasha had snacked a pawn on b2
but it does look like jeffrey got it
back
uh just going back to the position we
left it
um uh-huh jeffrey had some
ideas of snagging the queen
and he did get his pawn back and
well okay it looks like a pretty
balanced position
after all of the back and forth hikaru
versus
uh alireza
we can check in on again that was
looking very unpleasant for various
after rook g8
and um king e8 but
gosh more moves have passed and it's not
looking much prettier
well this is a really big moment right
here after this knight g3 because
the very best uh piece
that black had in the position was this
knight on e5
and if you have to play a move like
bishop
f8 it's all gone wrong because
you just go back a few moves and you go
here
so that you can go here uh no
this is not what black wanted
and it's what happened yeah and now it
looks
really bad the superior minor piece the
bad pawn structure
the increasingly bad pawn structure the
backward pawn on the e line
and all white has to say
as as far as giving you any hope is that
white has double pawns uh good luck
exploiting that
especially the fact that you have a dark
squared bishop and
the d-pawn on d3 is
on a light square so you're not going to
sell that one meantime
you've got buttons everywhere that are
weak h5
f5 e7 i mean this is just
lost exactly uh
the only question is do i start with
rook f5 or
rook a1 the e1 first but definitely
hikaru my pick in the driver's seat on
this one
just wanted to remind you guys what's
what
yesterday
you like your pick i like my pick a lot
in this round
okay magnus is doing tonight nice job
um this move d4
uh sets up just a really
i mean i think everybody's ever played
chess has fallen for a trap like this
yet in the game between wesley so okay
and
lanier dominguez and you look at this
position you go
oh i get it my opponent played c5 i
thought i was stopping that
because i'm i'm hitting c5 with the
knight in the pawn
i get it if i take with the pawn then
he's going to take my pawn
on e5 boom i'm not a big fan of that
i'll tell you what
i'll take the pawn on c5 with my knight
now if he takes with the bishop i'm not
going to take with the pawn and allow
queen takes i'll take with the queen
and i'll be very very happy
we suddenly get shocked by a nasty
rook takes d4 action we go oh
uh there's a trap so
knight so c5 sets up a very nice trap
and i have to confess on numerous
occasions i've fallen
into that type of oversight where
you know like in my in my glee at
winning a pawn
i forgot about the diagonal finish the
variation yes there's some
in the audience who may not see it as
clearly or at least want to see it on
the board as
yeah pointing out nice diagonal action
there
and that is going to get hammered to an
inch of his life after a glance on d8
and the queen takes on e5
as well so you're not gonna just take my
rook right away
and let me try to survive an end game
you're gonna you're gonna go for the
torture technique
yeah and maybe just simply uh yeah
until you have to right exactly so uh
knight takes e5 would be uh a blunder
galore
and speaking of the world champion
magnus carlson
uh we did see the intermezzo
uh takes on f7 shaq rook takes f7 queen
a3
uh decent move knight e6 and
everybody's favorite rook ad1 developing
with a
gain of tempo and now trying to go into
an end game
and that's the second time where magnus
says i'm not playing an end game
i love your king position it's just
so beautiful and i want to torture you
with this bad king now may i ask
what do you think is worse this king
position lavon had
lavon has in front of him or the king
position he had against grishchuck
oh that he manages for sure and that he
managed
to survive and even win the game
yeah we didn't think he was going to
make any comeback whatsoever
if he makes a second comeback i mean
just he is indeed a cat and and he's
used up three lives in this game
just being astonishing and also down on
the clock
16 minutes to 5 12.
i i i mean i get it but no
that's just too much to ask th this
looks like a real
real disaster i love the move rook on f1
to e1 what we used to call vladimir
kramnik's move
we used to joke about vladimir kramnik
that when he didn't know what to do in
almost any type of position by the way
he would play the move rook on f1 to e1
uh
just on the theory that the rooks belong
in the center of the board and uh
here we can see that uh rook e1
is in prep for knight f6 check when the
rook will suddenly be
magnificent on the open e file so
uh pawn and compensation for magnus he's
the one
enjoying uh what's going on in this game
a lot
c5 ooh
my spider dealing with the yeah dealing
with the diagonal
going off to the a pine who would have
thought yeah yeah
no pawn no matter how small uh
it should it should should not be uh
plucked
uh queen a3 grabs my attention i
wouldn't be surprised if the
there's even something uh more
uh forcing after all this rook on d1
really wants to plant itself on d6 but
queen a3
cannot be a bad move for uh magnus he's
looking really good let's go back to
nepo
and hari krishna what do we think about
this one guys we left it
not so far from here yeah well certainly
look
he's imposing for fergan as
um he hasn't given up any material to
have this
beautifully advanced d-pawn that is
holding all of white
pieces kind of bottled in and if you
fast forward a couple of moves rook d2
was played um and now bishop g7 with the
idea that
okay if you try to round up that pawn
sometimes there's going to be tactics
with fish of h6 right
so exactly yeah exactly gotta watch it
right rook d1 ship h6
right away definitely rookie three
bishop h6 skewers or x
so queen b3 was uh um harry's choice
you know this this thing about past
pawns it's really important to note
that they they're great
right obviously you tie pieces you tie
enemy pieces down
they will advance further and further
down the board but the biggest challenge
with them
is getting them all the way to the end
line
and if they're firmly blockaded then you
need to open up a second front
generally speaking in order to
show the helplessness of the opponent's
pieces
so here let's say bishop bishop a6 has
been played after queen b3
bishop e6 is on the board you play rook
back to d1
is what we would expect and then the
move
uh d2 and
rook to e2 i'm just going to play for
the moment
here getting rid of getting rid of that
rook
on uh rookie five is also playable
maybe let's play rookie five that's a
good idea as well but the point i'm
trying to make is the rook on d1
is annoying to get rid of like how do
you get it away
your only way to eject this piece is to
get a rook
on c1 or e1 right that's like the only
way to do it you cannot
remove this piece you just can't your
bishop is the wrong color
it is supporting the pawn on d2 but it
can help
shepherd the pawn to the very next
square this means that black needs
something else beyond this pawn
because there's just you can work a long
time and figure out
how to get this pawn moving to get the
rook
off the square well really it's to get
the rook off the square to get the pawn
moving
so where else will black go in order to
make it happen now there is an idea
of rook d3 takes on
f3 now that is creating
a new possibility for black so that
you could get some dynamism around the
king and potentially harass
the rook on d1 oh i like that idea but i
also had a boring idea
of just trying to trade queens because i
feel like
you know it's a really nice combination
rook and bishop versus
rook and knight um where where
as he has pointed out yesterday that
combination is particularly fruitful in
the end game
and so a queen d3 and no matter what
happens i feel like i'm going to start
harassing your queen type ones which
could be
overextended with my rooks and bishop
now what you're saying about that is
that you are looking for the second
front as well is to capture this pawn
right yep now he he played queen f6 in
the game
uh the trick the trick to be concerned
about we should point out
is if you're not careful in this end
game white can play for b5 c6
white won't just sit down and let you
attack there is a b5 c6 idea
as well and also he has king f1 and king
to e2
making it even harder to get past those
light squares
so this is this i mean it's a d-pawn on
d2
what more can you ask for it's fantastic
but you still have to
break the resistance and now we see rook
d3 on the board
after queen c4 you don't have to ask
any questions about what while black
plans to do on the next move
black is thinking i want a sack on f3
but if you guard f3
i'm thinking something like queen g4
forge oh no rook f3 is threatening
the rook on five as well so you have to
be mindful of that
uh this move you're playing queen e4 yes
rick f3 now is answered by pawn takes at
the worst case
so and queen e4
is indeed on the board queen e4 has been
played okay
so this is the point how do you break
and he's oh you sacked sorry you gotta
be excited
well i i i isn't it time to do what you
wanted to do
a long time ago maurice you said this
rook on d1 is such a
powerful blockading rook the only way to
get rid of it is to put a rook either on
c1 or
e1 so rook c3 and he's played rook c3 by
the way
yeah and somebody was also mentioning
that
b5 c6 on white's agenda so rook c3
uh getting the behind a past pound
really puts a kibosh on that
uh this looks really good for
black hold on i mean
i'm just thinking now king f1 king e2 is
that
just too ridiculous oh wait there's a
queen a6 problem
check there's a queen a6 maybe even
before
you played rook to c3 the moment uh the
king appeared on the board
the king appeared on f1 that could have
happened but maybe now it's even better
actually
because a2 is dropping so i if i can't
use the king i'm gonna have to use the
queen
so uh one thing i'm not 100
sure this rook on e5 is super
satisfactory
uh if i trade it off and go
full defensive mode if i seize the
defensive completely
uh rooksy one i'm
no i'm not i don't think i can capture
that pawn i'm pretty sure i can't
in fact uh i get i get uh
pinned badly with this move
um this looks really bad for
hari krishna i mean rook c3 with the
idea rook c1
uh it's interesting isn't it a few moves
ago you couldn't see how the river gets
to c3
and then the queen is there and then and
we get the idea and
that's there i mean it's all about
ejecting that rook can he get any
security his rook on e5
can't get back to the back row to just
simply defend the piece
which would make it fine for him and a
queen back to e2
what happens on a queen back to e2 so
let's just say king f1 rooksy one queen
e2 right just so that we can
nothing we're just simply getting
ourselves tied up maurice i mean the
queen is now
anchored to the rook um no the problem
here is we lose the a pawn just trade
and take on a2
i mean check trade check and take the
king on f1
allows for this straightforward tactic
and that's not acceptable here
okay so king f1 is not f1 was a
okay let me waste it a tempo another way
then
a good a good waste yeah it's not not
good
what should white be doing here the
knight on f3 needs to help as well
i don't see how to deal with the rook c1
threat
exactly i knew this was the way that we
knew we had to get rid of this rook
and somehow wise pieces left right left
the party and
now he's going to be resolving very
easily
we are seeing the move rookie 8 and i
must say that was actually my first
intent because you were seeing how the
rook on
e5 was somehow in the way whereas that
rook on d8 was
being uh very good at supporting the
spawn on d2
now the real problem for hari krishna is
that
his king's not on f1 so the desirable
queen e5 and king
on the e2 were just a tempo behind him
one tempo would have gotten him in to be
able to play this move
just and there was no no no guys
magnus carlton has defeated levon
aronian and now
lavonne um who came into the day with
such a beautiful score it's dropped down
but guess what kantala
harry krishna could find himself in the
same sequence also drop we talked about
this pairing
from the very top of the show guys and
we knew
it was going to be super hard for our
top our leaders to deal with the lineup
that was in front of them
and right away out the gate lavon had to
deal with magnus
why are they i see the two of them still
sitting there that seems a bit unusual
that's a little strange maybe they're
looking at the other games
okay after after we left it queen a3 was
played by the way uh
magnus uh greedily eyeing the a6 pawn
rook a7
by lavonne and this move queen a what a
posting that would be
on the b6 square just hitting a lot of
very nice targets in black's position a4
trying to break up the team on the queen
side and we saw
b4 well that is a pawn
and magnus said not interested
and i was mentioning that this rook oh
looks really good
queen okay that's a second pawn
oh boy a technical task and a pin on the
night
he just took it and moved and treated
that was too easy
that was too easy uh vaughn fell out of
bed this morning that
that that game really was not will not
go down
as a great game by lavon and
unfortunately for
uh indian fans hari krishna is really
just
a piece down and after check followed by
check i think it's a good time to give
it a rest a lot of fans for this man i
mean
i i'm impressed by harry in interviews
you could ask him um how the weather is
if you come up with a fascinating answer
but unfortunately not none is uh his
best game today either although i think
you know knuckles seemed to play really
well there at the end with the rookie
three rook c3 and
bishop g7 nice little quiet move of
you know just rerouting the bishop to
the h6 square to take over
d2 not supposed to be that easy jen not
supposed to be that easy though
uh that we noted that was the main plan
in the position
and harry just let it happen just
straight forward
get a rook to the back rank and that was
it by the way
if if i may i know one chat on this a
second
but wesley did a really
interesting move in the game against
lanier if you could jump to that on move
28 everything was all good for black
after this
c5 move we were talking about and we see
this trade rook five
guarding his pawn and
so rook f5 in this position so this is a
first of all
a pawn sack right and now g6
and look at this next move he said you
want my rook
yeah i'm offering it to you don't take
it though
you can have the rook check and oops
you're gonna be
mated if you move your king because
that's just too easy
and if you move it to g7 though what is
the
killer shot after same problem though
queen f5
what do you do i was gonna try oh you
have a queen g3 check as well but i
looked at queen g5 as mating isn't it
nice little mating setup nice pattern so
rook f1
with ideas of i don't know knight f6 and
rook h5 king uh g7
on the board and what's the time wesley
has been sitting here for quite some
time by the way
looking at this position he he hasn't
moved in a while his rook
is potentially hanging uh knight g5 he
might be thinking about it with the work
of
so is knight g5 possible let's take a
look at it and he's played it
it looks like he has played it looks
like he has played the move
it's on the board and instantly lanier
backed up well wait a minute you just
played king
g7 knight g5
king g8 wow
what and it looks like you still
can't take the rook could we add that as
a
reality as well no no you are going to
take and play f6
if we may call that a threat uh given
that we had taken
it the move before we would have taken
and we've got an issue right something
like
this and we've got check and
if you go to the f file we've got a rook
no this looks
you got to work on uh h8 hanging as well
yeah so that looks crushing so that was
why lanier dropped back with the rook
but
now the king came up and then he went
back
two free moves but can you take on f7
or do you have a queen h3 queen
three would force h5 right
yes exactly
looks um terrible after takes on essex
queen h3 was played and it looks like
that's gonna force h5
it certainly it's but don't you smell
something here like
yeah yeah
leslie is deep in thoughts look at look
at his
his head is there's a there's a bomb
about to land
there's a bomb that has to be landing
shortly on this board like how
does how how does white look at like
every possible legal move here right
you're looking at v6 knight f7
rook f6 but uh like queen g3
g3 played that doesn't feel like a bomb
introducing the idea i guess of knight
takes f7 is that
is that why we do that and then
afterwards
i thought that he was going to go queen
d3 to set up rook f7 ideas queen g3
didn't occur to me i was kind of
concerned about okay knight f7 is a
knight f7 looks like a threat though so
ah knight
f7 is wait a minute
is it okay did you just show me
is knight f7 i was gonna take on
f7 if i take your rook
you're gonna take again you're gonna
play the end game
well i was my you know what my dream was
was to
force your queen to some terrible square
like the thing is queen of four check
queen of four check but but it's not the
end of the story because your pawn is
going
really fast right yeah so amazing you
have to find to find the right square
for that king
like it looks like you actually have to
go to g8
or e8 e8 is also no e8
maybe even scary right right is scary
yes
so g8 so g8 and now e6 is not the
running
mate right you can hide no but it's
threatening your rook
they're sending e6 queen f7 um queen f8
i mean queen takes d8 correct
but you could be queening there and
there's a bishop f8 idea
so let's go through the line so say you
okay on a check
so well i i did it for a very specific
purpose uh
um jen i wanted to give you a back rank
nate that's not nice i'm going to have
to be forced to go queen c1 which is not
my
my basement then d2 comes immediately
i'd actually i i think we did it wrong
for wesley but
okay so the question is after h5 he has
played d3
it took him some time he had to walk
and knight f7 is on the board and knight
f7 immediately on the board
analysis uh
okay and then here we did rook takes f7
right this queen g6 i got rook g7
yeah that looks appealing so rook f7
queen f7 um merc f7
king of f7 and we did we did queen f4
check here right
oh did we we did do a queen
yes queen of four check was the move to
go after the bishop
and if you take the bishop well why
don't you take the bishop then
okay because you could do it in this way
but that's what i wanted to do that was
what my hope was
was to tie your queen down yeah exactly
yeah
that was so taking the bishop isn't
convincing me
well that's not easy either but look
what's happened in the game he's decided
to play instead
bishop to c5 with check anticipating
the long the long game the bishop is now
no longer on take
for later and and now the king is in the
corner as well so
he's got his last pawn you're not he's
hoping you're not winning anything
and if the king can somehow get to
safety then
bishop pawn and rook is worth a queen
like that's a given
especially this pawn yeah
and by the way um hikaru nakamura has
won against farrugia
oh that position was so big big start
for naka oh the final position looks
uh pretty cool so
uh white meets the strike right now and
he's gotta
he's got to do it very very quickly
before the moment i see the spawn on d2
i see only two results uh
reminds us of the nipple game
yeah yeah an echo right that that
that powerful pass deep on okay uh we're
seeing it twice
okay so how about check where is the
king going if you go
in this case to g8 i have queen
f6 with a double hit uh
looks very promising for white
e6 also no yeah i think
no isn't this where we gosh
uh e6 d2 now d2 i have the double check
and take yeah yes that's right so show
that on the board let's let's show that
on the board
yeah we saw this before i get to take
the rook
and you can't meet me because i've got
d1 covered
oops excuse me that was uh i hit the
wrong key there
oops that's not the right key where
where were we
okay so we could go back to well
yeah go back a couple of positions here
this is
yeah well this is the game position and
we're expecting queen f3
this is our movie it's been played and
king james has been played
and i don't know what to do about e6
king g8 is
yeah yeah that's right so similar to the
lines we were looking at but when rick
fa comes we get to just snap the pawn on
d3 that goes to show
it's almost like a double attack it's
like an anticipated double attack
yeah this is the main move i think
there's a problem here but guys
i mean uh playing and he did he played
e6
but the problem is because there's a
couple of attractive moves with the
queen as well queen
but i think queen c6 and queen f6
uh looked attractive and
and he just played king h7 by the way we
need to rush
guys i'm sorry sure but he's going fast
and he's found a way
to win the rook he played e6 he played a
check
his queen came back uh king 86 queen f4
check
and now kg7 and it looks like queen c7
check is just
a rook and you have to resign games
nice little geometry there finding the
long checks moves like that maneuvers
like that can be tough to see because
what could be better than having your
queen on f7 right against the king
looking like you're about to mate or
clean up on
but actually there is something even
better just winning the rook for free
and forcing resignation by the way
immediately
in hindsight that bishop c5 check which
we didn't look at
immediately no like that might have been
the culprit
because we were still trying to figure
out what to do with the bishop on b4
right now guys and it's an all decisive
day so far four out of four
wow this game is decisive it'll be five
decisive games to start up now look at
this material
love it three pieces versus a rook and a
bishop oh three pieces and upon yes
i don't want to tell your sensibilities
thank you thank you
this looks really good for black it sure
does
uh two minor pieces especially
in any kinds of endings where the pawns
that there's not pawns on both flanks
the two minor pieces really are awesome
they do
really dominate a rook and it looks like
jeffrey has a material imbalance that's
just terrible for him
i mean you want to play it solid right
is this what you tell your students uh
jen and maurice
play it very carefully don't rush
put your knight on f8 no the key the key
is to figure out where the knights
belong because
it's great to have knights but if
they're not doing anything then you have
a problem
to me i'm looking for anchor squares for
the knight one anchor square is d4
right if you put a knight on d4 and
protect it with a pawn on e5
there is nothing you can ever do about
this piece
the other square looks uh the other
square that looks good is the square
one knight is sitting on right now is e5
but you don't get both
a pawn on e5 and a knight on e5 so the
knight is actually draw back to g6
and to me he should be aiming to put the
knight somehow
on the d4 square and that should just
split white's position
in half and then the other knight should
be aiming for that pawn on g3 somehow
and make white advance it and keep
advancing until it just
gets too weak and will be assailable
he's dancing around with his knights at
the moment he has sufficient time for
the clock you would think
but just about where should
the night the knights go bishop is on an
anchor square
knights need an anchor square somehow
and this is how they're going to
coordinate
at the moment you're up material but so
what if your pieces aren't attacking
anything well he's about to
uh play knight h5 and try to provoke
this pawn
the first cross a little bit forwards
so then we have one very uh
nice f4 square and
jeffrey there's a night check
knight that's just the worst way to
defend
five decisive games wow
whoa i i think the the fine the this
position is losing
but i mean black had to work for it
king f3 was not recommended uh isn't
that interesting
isn't it interesting it happens to us as
players
that you're thinking about a position
you realize
there's one tiny weakness but it's real
that g-pawn knight h5 is coming you're
going to have to anticipate dealing with
that so be ready to play the move g4
so you start getting lost in thoughts
abstract thoughts about this
this specific weakness something's going
to come to f4 with check
after you play g4 so why don't i
anticipate
deeply by putting my king on the square
of three
anyway right in advance so you're
thinking all those
deep thoughts and you forget on the very
first move
oh right there's a fork yeah we thought
happened to the best of them even magnus
carlton with that move order
mishap and the 960. jennifer just to
review you said we had
all decisive games to start
funny start for the day guys wow
we didn't even have an all decisive
round in 9lx
wow that is remarkable uh i'm just
reviewing a little bit the sicaru game
i'm
hikaru ended up with a lot of past pawns
and three connected past pawns he said
uh i'm prepared to sacrifice my rook
so that i will get my advanced pawns and
that's exactly what happened um
alibiza did win the rook that
too many pawns gee yeah just way way way
too
fast and the king is going to come
together
don't we have two brand new leaders
what's it wesley
and nepo we're leaving we're right
behind
the two of them that's right they have
flipped as
jan and wesley were in third joint third
um last round and now they pop
into the lead while lavon and pantala
are now
enjoying third but someone else is
joined world champion magnus carlson
with a nice bounce-back game
against lavana ronian um nakamura now
on an even score um feeling a lot better
after yesterday's tough start and griez
also with a little bit of wind in his
house
absolutely and unfortunately ali riza
jeffrey the junior players it seems like
they're not ready to take on the big
lions quite yet jen
five rounds
so i think they need to do decently in
the rapid they can really show some
some fine stuff in the blitz they were
they were born on online blitz right
that's true that's true they were
yep and uh we're just gonna
as we take a break we're gonna show you
a very nice highlight from a 2018 rapid
and blitz
uh between shaq and nakamura
you may bring back some nice memories be
right back
game has changed dramatically two
shocking moves
now it's just about the light square
bishop figuring out what to do king b2
bringing the king into the game as well
rook to d7
rook to d7 c3 and bishop f5
those last two moves by white leasing oh
i like it i don't like it i like it
uh maurice bishop f3 h5 preparing rook
g5 ideas
h5 i like that roof too i don't
understand by the way we have a big
score
mvl has drawn his game but what's this
about
he just played he came back to a1 i
don't like what's going on
what was king a1 now we can't play
rookies
i can defend the b1 square with the move
d3 so look at that
king it's just terrible and how do you
make progress here
oh oh oh bishop it
three to stop the rook from getting the
b7 but then bishop
oh you put the original one d5 correct i
want to put the bishop on d
and then we can move her and i want to
be able to play e4 g4
bishop g4 giving up one of the two
businesses i wouldn't have guessed that
move i would have
wanted to keep my bishops i was thinking
maybe bishop d
wanda b3 to keep the two bishops does he
have to trade immediately
yeah i'm surprised he took so long and
he hasn't played h6
shutting that down but the king on a1 is
terrible yeah
king on c2 that maneuver did not make
any sense
now he's shut out of the play now the
rooks have doubled but he's bringing his
rook back
and what does how does white make
progress here
wait but white can at least put his
origins but he doesn't have to bring it
he did bring it he could have played
king a2
he did bishop rook b1 was not a threat
okay white still white now has the game
under control
but the question is how to make progress
right it's all about
d7 rook g2 he cannot let the king the
white king get in the game
no he'll go back control this king he
will
he'll put a rook back on the b-file e7
is the blue
and king a2 just just
get it up to the b3 what about d4 d4
oh yeah he just moved this rook away
from the file bring the king in king
b6 rook check move the king over he
didn't have to be asked twice
oh yeah he's happy about this and now
the bishop will come back to guard b2
and that's all covered
work b6 bishop c1 we got bishop c1
but there was that big question you
asked a moment ago what about d4
well not right now no no he's also down
on the clock
all right bishop c1 being played has
been played yes
and now he's ready to march his pawns
forward
maybe d4 d4 yes well there's rook
g6 in the position rook g6
ah but rook a1 can be annoying
is it really annoying
what is it doing rook a1 and then rook
a2 check is the last check isn't it
the bishop is going to need flexibility
this is going to need a room somehow
and also by the way this bishop on on
c1 is really anemia clock too
okay but this check king c3 rook b1
harassing the bishop oh he's played king
d3
rook whoa he's stepped back into a play
slick guarding though slick because he's
well
the thing is black's king can be
introduced and black is stymied about
what he can do on that side if he plays
rook to a1 king c2
and then the everything is frozen he's
well defended and he's the one
with the initiative with his d5 e4 yeah
let's go
so why shouldn't baby white is okay for
the moment in a check and now the king
is marched up
and now he's going after the five
rook c3 rook c3 is oh he traps the
bishop
yeah well he gets it
he can't only on uh ravel in this
position
rook b3 c3 traps the bishop or
this one nakamura about to win this game
the pawn is not dangerous
enough the c pawn he plays king d5 but
that looks like
it's hanging the bishop is hanging and
he has to resign and there it is wow
fantastic defense buy did a car just
seal the deal he sealed the deal
the game the tournament is over there's
your yeah
champion he's got 22 and a half points
with maxine bashar lagrave and
wow at 20 and a half no one can catch
this man
we were all right nakamura is the saint
louis raptor blitz champion
hello and welcome back to the saint
louis rapid and blitz i'm jennifer
jahati i'm here with yasser sarwan and
maurice ashley and
what around four we had guys
we did we certainly did a 5-zip but i
must say that on our break i really
enjoyed
that clip a real precursor to the type
of blitz action we're going to see
but here's our current standings jen
yeah well
we mentioned it right before the break
jan
and wesley have leapfrogged over lavonne
and harry um after those dramatic round
four results
and what's coming up for their next
pairings
well they're gonna get more and more
tents as the tournament reaches its
midpoint right now
uh magnus carlsen playing black against
the ninjas
um who just lost his game while
um ferozia and so are facing off yan
playing against a wounded jeffrey zhang
as well
so uh these pairings right now seem
like the wounded versus victorious well
except
lavonne is playing fintala just had the
lead
they just were together in first and now
they crash and burn from the last game
and will have to face off
against each other will they make a
quick draw just to
try to right the ship get the mental the
mental
batteries recharged or though someone
say you know what
i'm sorry you gotta step back i'm trying
to get back to the front again
exactly well uh one question for you
what do you think uh about the
draw percentages uh comparing
comparatively speaking uh
of the three types of
time controls uh jen here we have a
graphic
that's right well the faster the chess
the fewer the draws and
we know that maurice certainly loves
that but don't we all
we all love those decisive games blood
on the board okay there are plenty of
super entertaining draws
but it's nice when they're the exception
not the rule
and um these draw rates since 1999 you
know it would be great
to get a breakdown more precisely um
as to recent events and
i i think they said these are these
statistics are what you might intuit
though right that the faster you go
the the fewer draws you have all right
that would have definitely been my
common sense kind of thinking
that yeah as you get into the blitz uh
the decisive number
of games go decisive percentage goes
up well and why is that
because well because you time travel
makes fools of us all
maurice and uh crop in
people can't play perfect chess with all
that time on their clock because they
only have
a little bit of time on their clock and
there's not that much
look at that what we need the cat cam
come on guys oh that's way too hot
oh my god that cat is a boss it's not
just a cat it's the way
look how lovingly they're sharing that
space together
oh that's awesome oh does he know he's
on camera
just love some wesley sew that's awesome
adorable
don't don't leave keep this stride
nice i actually don't have a cat but i i
love
i do like i do really like kitty cats
clearly wesley does too apparently
he looked like he was in his pj's wait
why did he know
leslie if i'd known that he was playing
with a cat as his second guy
that would have been my thing wow good
you didn't know
now in our next uh round uh
what is going to be our marquee game we
have lanier and magnus
ali ruja and wesley and ikaru yan
and jeffrey and finally lavon
and hari krishna who were just our turn
to tournament leaders
that would have been it right but not
right now it doesn't feel like fun
i always like watching john's games and
i feel like jeffrey is such an
interesting player that
that might be like my top pick from the
get-go
because john is a co-leader and he
always plays so quickly so it's not like
we have to sit around for a long time
figuring out how he's gonna develop
um but um yeah i that's my that's my
number one fave
okay we'll start with it
we'll start with it who hasn't gotten
any love from us though because jan did
just get some love from the last
game um but while we while we ponder
that
look at this incredible oktoberfest
is coming up and i love the way this is
working guys because everybody gets
their moment to shine
um all of these events are going to be
held separately the u.s junior girls the
us junior the seniors the women's
championship
and of course the overall u.s
championship and
so we're gonna be able to have our our
sole attention on the games of
you know legends like larry christensen
and joel benjamin from october 17 to
19th um
really really fun format and some
wonderful chats in store for
all bands it looks like it's going to be
a series of tournaments based on rapid
chess jim
yes it's rapid chess so it's 12 player
round robins for the women's and the
overall
the other events are all 10 player round
robins so it's going to be
three days of chess similar to the rapid
portion of the saint louis rapid and
blitz for um
the uh the ten player tournaments which
is the senior the junior and the junior
girls
and then we will go to a four full day
schedule
did i say four four and four i feel like
i keep flipping those words but a full
four day schedule
for uh the women's and the us
championship and those events
are going to crown national champions
the crowning national champions
and the prize fund has remained almost
exactly the same which again
wow um incredibly generous as
you know many of the players who haven't
gotten in these massive invitations
over the summer because most of those
were these elite round robins
are going to be invited to these
tournaments that it's going to be their
first big money event of the
of the summer or i guess fall now and
i'm sure that everybody's just so
appreciative that these events are
online with those same prize funds
and those juniors who sometimes would
have to skip
championships because of school right
and you say you know what
i think i'll play in this one because
i'm doing work
online anyway right i could take a break
i'm sure that
the professors won't say no no no no you
gotta show up for my zoom class
well you can yeah i mean maybe just put
the zoom on
turn the camera just kidding
um but yeah the virtual learning does
allow for a lot more flexibility because
a lot of times those classes are
recorded
um and i actually had some of my
students from my girls club at
in the u.s chess women's program tell me
that they were watching
us on one monitor and then doing their
their virtual learning on another
multitasking multitasking indeed well
double virtual learning
yeah the younger generation can pull
that off easily they can't even turn
some music on
while doing both of those things as well
and have the phone out texting
yeah it is impressive it's extraordinary
can't believe it when i watch my kids do
it's like they can text without looking
at the phone basically
they got the tv on and doing work
like i was like you can't possibly be
concentrating like
duh we are as long as they brought home
the a's it didn't matter so
they got the a's nice nice um the games
are about to
begin momentarily any predictions um
like what opening do you think dominguez
carlson is gonna be i think it's going
to be
i think it's going to be e4 e5 i'm going
to go with the
i was about to say berlin but i really
wanted to say philadelphia
oh indeed and i think it's the d4
variation
with the knight taking on d4 not queen
takes as we see it
quickly happening now so we can get to
that
uh looks looks like magnus is taking a
page out of
is it dupoff's book yeah i was about to
say
danielle has been uh as
ubova has been playing the philidor for
many many years donald
recently started came up with some
really intriguing ideas
and bishop f4 queen d2 um
at first blush uh you wouldn't think
that the bishop
really belongs on f4 after all isn't the
structure of c7 d6
rather rock solid but the idea is a
little bit deeper
than that it's not that you want to play
e5 it's really that you want to
discourage
uh the move d5 if black ends up playing
d5 we can all
understand that in fact yes the bishop
could
be very well placed on f4 so bishop f4
queen d2
uh preparing castles and well
magnus has stopped just simply
uh stopped in what is a very topical
position these days
and in this position with levon aronian
and vittala hari krishna
you'll be happy as as the debate with
the karo khan particularly
the advance variation continues
as pantala did play
the move uh c6 on move one and
and after e5 by levon plays bishop f5
but lavon doesn't want to see any queen
trades he did drop his queen back to d1
that's the purpose of having the knight
on e2
now we've seen a number of times the
inclusion
of the moves h4a h5 sorry to interrupt
you maurice
but bishop d3 was played immediately
instead of that and
this is where we saw sometimes this
jacket queen a6
in the nakamura game versus furusha
combined with e6 but again that was the
inclusion of h4h5
in this case there's no h4h5 the knight
comes to e2 a little bit more flexible
than on the f3 square
right so this game is this game is the
game between aronian and hari krishna
and so this position we see here
with the knight on e2 i was always
taught yes that with the knight on e2
that this maneuver by black was not
that effective putting the queen on a6
if you could castle easily and then just
bomb rush the the king side of whites
of blacks excuse me white is able to
just castle bring pieces out
and get going with like an f4 push f5
potentially
that this queen that you should wait
until the knight got to f3
before you played the queen a5 queen a6
idea
what's uh what's the wrinkle that makes
this queen on a6
so strong even though white is able to
castle quite easily
i'm not sure i i i i'm just not sure
uh one of the ideas of queen a6 is you
know like you say you don't want to stop
the guy from
castling and putting your queen on the
diagonal the other thing that the queen
on a6 sometimes does discourage
is that the queen can show up on d on
the front door
uh uh with queen d3 uh
i'm not sure what the queen is doing on
a6
a varus and a cobian would tell you oh
your queen belongs on b6 your knight
belongs on c6 you need to put pressure
on the d4 pawn by playing knight h6 and
knight
f5 and that's what you got to do your
queen
actually doesn't belong on a6 this might
just be a
a wrinkle that has to do with this very
very specific
position in general yes if the knight is
on f3 the queen on a6 looks very good
with the knight on e2 it looks less good
on a6
very strange yeah let's just uh
interesting
dropping that you wanted to
see jen and look at this after e4
and alekhine's defense okay alakine
defense
overrated underrated correctly rated
underestimated all right all right like
it
underestimate free in a way because i
feel like a lot of the positions i see
with black and the alakan don't look as
bad as one might expect from getting
your knight chased around so early in
the game
like this one for instance right
well 95 queen f3
man queen f3 that's just like that's
like
you know a slap in the face that's that
says i'm gonna try to refute you
uh where as a chess coach you know you
kind of
tell your your students you know be
leery
be wary of uh developing your queen
early
but queen f3 now why bishop c4 and why
not
c4 because the the thing about queen f3
was
it it had an attack on f7 but it also
looks towards b7 but
um this move could be a little greedy
right yes
yes precisely because uh there are
counter issues uh including knight c2
check
give me the rook and including queen
takes d4
i think we have all fallen at one time
or another for such a tactic
as this royal fort no
and fighting a horrible game yeah
so that that brute force method doesn't
work so white gets on with
his development now there is one very
nice uh
checkmating idea that we should all uh
be very familiar with the move like
night before and you're thinking to
yourself
then i can't wait to play queen takes d4
and knight takes e2
well you're gonna have your universe
rocked when somebody lands queen f7 and
bishop f7
oops i feel bad that's a pretty one
a pretty pattern don't move the knight
and jeffrey did not move his knight he
instead he played bishop g7
uh preparing castles and
uh of course knight before starts to
be attractive once the king is tucked
away
good point yeah because also when we
when you take on e6 we can sometimes
recapture with the temple in the queen
but actually that queen went to b3 okay
um adding some pressure to b7 so queen
takes b7 now as a possibility
looks really wrong to me i mean sorry
uh
queen b7 and i guess you're you're
trying to play night eight
not oh you're playing knight before okay
oh yeah oh yeah
i definitely want to play knight and now
if i play like
bishop b5 check trying to get your king
um destabilized um
yep it is destabilized but yeah right a
second
thing about your position my friend
jeremy sillman and i used to
play a lot of blitz together and he had
this great a great great way of saying
my turn you know you played with my king
f8
and i'm facing a multiplicity of
threats and it's like now you know you
got your check but it's my
turn uh knight knight c6 looks
good uh for black because
you gotta take right and then suddenly
um
isn't isn't black the one with all the
activity
i see what you're saying so if i play
like a a quiet move here like c3 after
knight c6
um no after i want to take on c6 first
yes
yes after 96 pawn c6 c3 like some kind
of quiet move the problem is after rook
v8
i'm running into some tactics with the
uh bishop being undefended on c4 like if
i play
queen t1 you might even just have
something like knight take c3
and you win upon and you're going to get
this
lovely bishop on c4 preventing castling
you had me at uh you win a pawn
yeah you're gonna stop right there
uh by the way yes by the way
i mean this one is interesting to be
sure and jeffrey's
pondering the nuances knight c6 yeah
but take a look at the barn burner
between lanier and
magnus coming out of this philidor
like this is the kind of game we want to
follow
start stock magnus decided after queen
d2 to play
c6 and after castles play
b5 f3 b4 knight b1
a5 and lanier didn't back down he said
okay
you can storm well i can one-up you and
i'm gonna storm on the other side
with a tactic hitting your knight on f
and f6 actually he's this is just
imitation being the sincerest form
of flattery because that's what magnus
just did to his knight on the other side
of the board by
playing b4 so here go two
tremendous pawn storms and magnus has
not only ignored the g5 move
he sacrificed a pawn with the move
with the move a4 but it's not really a
sacrifice queetig's b4 is meant by c5
thank you for the peace so here we go
guys
look at this attacking crazy
wild wooly affair okay this is really
this is great stuff this is great stuff
but i gotta tell you
i would be sweating cannonballs if i was
black i mean
not if i was white the night on b1 no
i'm not happy about it but it
offers comfort what i'm really really
ecstatic about i'm doing cart cartwheels
and backflips
what about knight f5 uh threatening 97
bishop d6
killing if you take which i
more or less think you gotta do i've
just opened up the g
file and wow i'm gonna get there
fast down the g file what do you think
about them apples
i got to tell you i'm seeing a d6 pawn
hanging which i know
you'll pretend you want to attack but
you'll decide to take the pawn
along the way and then laugh at me
because you got a free pawn for no
reason
you do have the two bishops the b pawn
once again now we will take it that is
hanging
especially now that the knight has moved
because the knight is moved
you resolve that problem and oh you were
mentioning your attack with rook g1
like yeah what's not to like this that
looks tremendous
knight f5 just looks like a great move
in this position and i was going to say
you know lanier's problem
typical he spends a lot of time thinking
he's going to get in some
time pressure potentially look at the
clock situation
lanier is the one who's up three minutes
on the clock
and magnus is the one who's taking some
time to play this very risky
let's call it risky potentially
you know i don't know what word to put
on there i mean i know some words i
could use
but i'm not liking black as you i agree
with you 100
i'm really not liking black hair if if
i'm in linear shoes this is
absolutely the kind of chaotic mess on
the board that i want to see
when i'm playing against magnus i've
never played with magnus but
if i were to play against magnus i
wouldn't want one of those
calm positional
grinds where we both fight over the e5
square or maybe we'll fight over the c7
pawn
but i want a donny brook and you know
wide open
chaotic with kings on opposite flanks
where i'm in there with a really good
chance of
of a knockout blow and i'm a little bit
surprised that
magnus says said okay you know
lanier i may be black i want to get you
i'm going to play a very very risky uh
middle game position because that's what
the world champion has decided to do
he's
that there's no coming back from from
from this one guys there's no way to
let's let let's tamp it down you know
tap it down a little bit let's get rid
of some of the excess energy
knight f5 is going to be real challenge
let's go down the line though because
there's only one move it looks like
against knight f5
after captures captures is the move d5
precisely you gotta i mean just because
there's so many threats of
uh from white's point of view queen b4
is significant bishop d6
is the other pawn grab so d5 deals with
effectively deals with both uh you get
your pawn
and i was going to play rook g1 and i
was hoping for the trap
don't even think of capturing my pawn
because you're gonna
you're gonna be really unhappy uh
dealing with this this is the double
threat of maiden one and the queen but
of course you're not gonna take
you'll develop your knight instead um
well can i go a little bit
well not um jen help me out here do you
like bishop
h6 or e5 i like e5
well yeah bishop h6 i guess on 90
what it there's 98 right it's not
yeah yeah and i i mean i would love to
do bishop takes g7 type stuff but
essex is just so well defended at the
moment
right i mean i i can't i can't even uh
grab the d-pawn but
i feel like so maybe yeah
yeah e5 has got to be happiness right
you black's gonna have to sacrifice a
piece here i just don't see
any yeah that looks really bad so
e5 yeah whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait wait
wait wait wait okay so i'm just trying
i'm just trying to track
your analysis so e so this move e5
knight h5 knight h5 f6
that's a nasty yeah you could sacrifice
a ps you know you can take on f6
and and i can't play bishop c5 because
you're going to sock on g7 and play
queen
g2 no you can't cycle on g7 because i
have knight f6 as the
as the stopper there maybe knight
maybe rook
let's just look guys at a very
interesting
moment in the game between krishak and
nakamura um
our team is alerting us and
varujanikovian um says that
greishak has a great opportunity here
um after b5
um apparently he missed it and the move
that he missed i'm hearing
is after b5 oh
b5 included yes after b5 rook c8 this
was the moment
that white missed a big opportunity
really okay
if it's something like knight takes d5
yeah sacrificing the queen in knight e7
i don't know that's asking a lot for a
rapid game
i mean wow that looks like what
what uh what he meant now he takes d5
let's take a look let's take a look
rick takes e3 97 check king fa
so what's the idea here tonight do we
have the in between move well pawn takes
e6
you just have rook takes c6 right
uh yes we do maybe i should have put my
king on
h8 because i i'm i'm starting to stare a
little bit at the bishop d6
true and then i put my if i put my king
on no no he's taking your rook
he's taking your rope sorry um okay what
sorry i missed that so king fa bishop
say bishop d6 king e8
now what so i've given up my
queen for a bishop for a bishop no but
you can take the
there's a b8 problem all the way to the
air of course we're going to take the
rock
yeah okay take the rook ca now what's
the material balance here all we have is
a
a rook it's enough take the baby take
the pawn take the
take the pawn okay and now on b
threatening i'm threatening to take on
c6
so correct with either one and yet the
knight b6 is met by taking on c6
i believe in the pawn no oh with the
pawn
that's what that's what i wanted to do
was take with the pawn because i'm
seeing the v8 square
this is an incredible conception i mean
this would be something like even if
somebody came up with this idea and won
in a classical game we'd be throwing
goats
but in a wrapping game very nice very
nice
but okay i mean it's easy to overlook a
move like knight d5 i'm not gonna be
critical of that that's an amazing
conception or to evaluate it
like as good even though you're down a
rook for a queen um
i mean i'm sure it crossed his mind may
take c5 right like player
of that level is always looking at all
the forcing moves and sacrifices
but to evaluate all the way down the
line that's marvelous
yeah and instead he played a more
positional continuation and it
looks pretty balanced now
okay let's go back to one of our
tournament leader
well there's a there's a knight on c2
guys wait a minute
what what just happened uh we did see
no we did not see knight c6 i apologize
so bishop e5 de5 knight c6
oh okay so queen cause seven
why okay now nice round running
queen threatening to trap the queen
right
bishop to b5 i mean not just threatening
to trap the queen but
threatening the bishop on c4 and the
pawn on c2
that's a lot of threats i mean there's
in one move
you're right triple threat one two
three threats yep yeah the triple threat
so he dealt with
a couple of those but he couldn't deal
with this one
now and now castles
you just castle there that's
cold-blooded wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute hold on are we mated
bishop c4 check the king's gonna go for
a walk
bishop c4 check king goes queen d3
check we got to go bishop e3 right
yeah i mean let's try to be three three
okay now um queenie two check
be careful these king walks it's
important that you don't let them get
out
uh
queen e3 you have bishop f3
but um the point here is i'm not down
that much material guys i'm only down
a piece for two pawns after queen takes
e5
no that's completely winning now because
queen e5
after king f2 now it's time to
introduce the rook yeah yeah
that that for a second i was analyzing
thinking that we were down like a rook
and three problems
i was like wait a second we're only down
a piece for two pawns we got that
this is this is this is a no-brainer
bishop c4
check i think jeffrey's completely
so wait what on earth happened there
like what was the blunder
queen takes b7 right you can't just
snack on this pawn you know i had a game
i had a game against patrick wolf
in the mid 90s i think it was 1995
95 right now u.s champion patrick yeah
yeah good good friend i was like even
his second
uh in beale when he was going for the
in the candidates and we played a game
where this almost exact same thing
happened the
the queen went after the b7 pawn taking
a night on cd6
i castled because attack the tactics
allowed me to get rickett in rook b8 and
rook b6 and takes
i didn't win the game would have been
one of the great games great wins of my
life i found a great move g5
in that game it's one of just
one of the best games i've ever played
up to the point where i screwed it up
and ended up only getting a draw out of
it because i thought i was chasing his
king
around and the king i would catch the
king by
chasing it and he ended up being able to
slip the noose and i had to force a
repetition
that's why i'm so concerned about the
king in this position
because i'm having flashbacks to that
game
where if you're not careful the king
gets out
and that's what that's exactly what
jeffrey is doing right now he's trying
to figure out can he get away with
with uh something else nuanced and he
played rook to b8
instead of bishop c4 but this does allow
queen
or does it allow queen to a6 stopping
bishop to c4
true so we can bring in the queen and
bring in the big gun
queen d4 threatening bishop c4 winning
your queen
friending queen takes e5 uh do i have
any other threats
you don't need any of these i'm
terrified i mean you're a wicked person
man
you named all those threats and you want
more
wow i'm feeling bad evil
i'm feeling bad as it is i mean wow okay
just a second can i deal with i i
understand what you mean jen but can i
deal with the threat of bishop c4
check by knight d2 now right and then
when i take your pawn on e5
oh man where am i no this is and he's
playing queen a7 guys
allowing bishop to c4
black has everything
every now bishop c4 and start the hunt
i mean this this looks ugly there's
got to be a straight well well let's
find it is bishop c4
yeah okay let's bring in the queen again
queen d3 check that's what we did last
time right and you can't play queen d3
you have to play bishop e3
material is what we're down just this is
contract
we're down a piece we can actually win
the piece back if we felt like
it with knight d i know we don't but
yeah
first you're saying fourth win worst
worst case right we can win that so
let's go after
if we can't force the mate because we
were like
here here a while ago right it should be
three mm-hmm
oh no no no in this case in this case
i'm sorry last time we were playing
i i i i made a mistake sorry i
i was playing 93 from bishop on e3
although i mean even there queen e2 king
g3 rook takes b2 but
the king is get got out of dodge right
right right no we don't like that
uh um what do we like
by the way by the way jeffrey played
knight back
to d4 with check okay nippo played
king back to e1 which of course we could
repeat everything with knight to c2
check just to restart or we could play
knight takes bishop now that you can't
castle
but you got to feel like there's got to
be a cleaner win in this position than
this
true but knight takes e6 looks really
good i mean oh but
let's put that king back on f3 come on
let's find something yeah
we're good enough to find some kind of
castle you can't castle
bishop c4 let's do that bishop c4 king
f3
queen d i think you are on to something
yeah you said we need to get the right
in play bishop
i was about ready to suggest f6
to uh
introduce another gun into the game yes
precisely
you know the problem excuse me the
problem with my game with patrick
was my rook on b8 wanted to get into the
game
right they wanted to get into the game
uh
and along along the fourth rank
or the fifth rank that was the challenge
so note
that in this situation rook can go to b4
right and be and suggest
something if you can't find a move
suggest something along the fourth rank
feel me you see the mating idea even
something like a queen f5
and move the bishop out of the way and
suddenly you're getting mated right
that's right that's the key there so we
go back to the analysis board and
take a look at that is it is it a rook
before or is it just a force line
with queenify first then rook b4
i just feel like you know i know it's
just something
hiding in there but i can't figure out
so that you can somehow uh
force a queen g4 or g4 kind of mate
uh crazy there's got to be anything yeah
i really think that rook on
b8 if it's going to go anywhere it
really needs to land on b2 i'm just
that's another option yeah i'm just a
little shocked that
i don't have a completely forcing
win bishop d5 check trade trade king g3
that doesn't
are you sure it's not in just a second
what do we what are we sure about
because
by the way i can always take this rook
too
hold on if you're telling me i'm a piece
down i could be in exchange
whatever i want okay this is true this
is true
but look at look at the youngster he's
been thinking for a long time
jeffrey has and he's the the thing i
would think he's thinking about is
should i take that bishop now
or play a knight c2 and then look at all
those variations
but yeah as you make a very good point
if we can
always take the rook right why not go
for this line
if it all comes to where we can't figure
out a mate
the rook is sitting there waiting to be
snapped on it's a rock
it can't be it can't be bad i mean from
a practical standpoint
your night's getting out yeah the rook
is taking on b2
the opponent the only thing you might
worry about is something like bishop e4
but queenie two check
solves that problem pretty directly so
bishop d5 as does bishop d5 so
i mean in the worst case he can do that
i think i think he's looking for
mate that's what his problem is he's
looking for me
and it may well be there but he's that's
what he's looking for
okay knight takes a1 i do apologize that
really is a yasser sarah one move you
know
give me the material that is not a
michael tall move come on michael tall
you're
you give this position to michael taller
gary kasparov he says
i don't want your stinking rook uh
something
i'm missing something here we may have
to we may have to call
in var here but this
i mean come on you can't get away with
this your king is
your king is yeah it looks
horrible it looks horrible i mean why he
worked the eighth running
knight which rook this one
this one decided maybe maybe the other
one because
your ideas of f6 in case they came into
play
but i know but that's weird because that
one can take b2 okay yeah
sure also we do have just rook takes
beating
the b2 is good looking good too i mean
there's so many moves
this is the problem that he faces
there's too many moves he must be
winning
he knows it but he's looking for a mate
and it doesn't look like there's a
forced mate i think that's the problem
there's no check check check this move
mate you're finished
it doesn't look that way and he's still
looking and at some point he's gonna
have to decide to bail
from a practical standpoint nepal is
hoping he bails at two minutes
right like yeah okay now instead of
cause he's at six minutes he's ten
minutes down about to be 10 minutes down
on the clock
and he has to make a decision it's a
rapid game you have to be smart and make
a decision
he's finally decided on the move rook
to he played nicely to king e2 and rook
to b6
in this position this makes some sense
so he's trying to play bishop c4 check
in those queen d3 lines without having
the bishop e3 is an adequate defense
knight a3
was a quick reply by ayan napongnichi
not letting
instant yeah you know i guess he
probably knows his position as rotten
and figures
you know he should just try to you know
put that time pressure on jeffrey see if
he can get him down to a minute
um we know yan likes to play very
quickly sometimes
but that queen that queen is looking
very close to trapped by the way
yeah yeah right knight before check and
knight takes c6
very attractive and this reminds me of
that game with patrick
it's so close except patrick actually
had his king castled
that king was in the middle not just i
would have done work
but what is nepo's intention
after rook takes c6 by the way just
defending
this uh knight develop the bishop right
or oh no development because you're
gonna take a rook if you take the rook
what's the material
yeah something like that maybe okay
although okay
i'm a little scared about the attack
still i wasn't gonna play that much
bishop e3 but he's trying to he's trying
to hope against hope to get his pieces
out knight d4
check played and i think that means he's
gonna take on c6
what's the material after he takes on c6
one pawn
for your king sitting in the middle of
the board never the castle
by the way that uh one pawn uh i'll take
that back
it's not even a pawn i mean oh yeah
thanks for keeping count yeah isn't the
only way to
count on me for that guys if you're
playing over the board game maybe your
best chance is to just tuck your king
and castle and and hope for the best
well that's what has happened i i
if you're going to take a pawn do it
with real
gusto uh queen coming to d5
now we're talking i mean
you're cleaning out so many great
options queen d5 is beautiful
but he did choose the more prosaic
knight takes e5
he's in practical mode now that's very
important it it's clear that there was
something there
that black could have done that maybe it
was different
we feel it we know there was something
maybe it was super deep
none of us saw it jeffrey said i don't
see it
so it's it's too deep i'm sure people
using
the computers know what it was that's
right
but you're when you're sitting at the
board and the clock is ticking down
and you got to make practical moves
you've got to make a good decision and
what he's done is he said
we now have exactly even material now
let's check to see who's better
developed
let's see whose king is me let's see
who can continue to make easy moves
knight d3 is coming
queen centralized is coming other rooks
showing up let's see
you find the move knight on a3 no moves
bishop on c1 if you move be careful i
got the b2 pawn hanging
you're king when when you try to castle
it there's going to be this rule that
says you can't
yeah you moved it about 15 times already
imagine if you're a fan of yan the palm
that she's here and you're like okay
maybe he survived the worst just he
finally gets the castle
right then you you scroll up and you're
like oh no why can't he castle okay
no no can't do you know if he could
castle in this position
in this exact position if he could
castle maybe it's not so bad
life is not so bad it's been important
to be able to cast
if he could just castle life would be
somebody he played bishop 86 hitting
rook and jeffrey stylishly
just centralizes queen and says you can
have my stinking rook
i'm hunting big game queen g2 by the way
you can't castle queen side either
oh boy that looks like a very powerful
move
uh sorry guys that this is absolutely a
great game there's no question about it
but i
i really want to see also what's
happening with magnus
uh let me hunt him down he was up
against lanier remember
that was a game that we thought you know
and
by the way lanier did not play knight f5
he played h4 c5
he only
why didn't you like to do okay
we chose a good time to leave this game
by the way because it's like four moves
got played
that's all that's it they were difficult
moves but
queen g2 king h8 on the board we've
caught up with the players
but okay we gotta get we got to leave
this game yes because
okay there's no way i doubt that we have
to leave this game let's get back to the
the leader about to potentially lose
to the teenager that's got to be
because i still want to understand guys
after bishop h6 queen d5
um the knockout after bishop takes off
eight it's just queen takes g2
just queen takes up two and now if you
were to play
work f1 i just want to see some pretty
mates on the board
i'm sure night out john doesn't want to
see that i'm sorry john
but this has been a great game by
jeffrey let us have some fun ruth takes
v2 oh
running um knight knight f3
and king d1 queen f1 mating don't forget
bishop h3 as well bishop
is just like straight forward everything
isn't happening
he played pawn to f3 he got it but now
okay uh b2 is hanging
with a mate mate thread bishop f8 queen
d2 and queen f2 is mate
what about d8 just to make you
no no no come on i don't know wait a
minute what am i talking about
not only is it delish but this amazing
idea is suddenly
everywhere right 93 and uh
knight f3 queenie five check exactly
exactly wow this is an evisceration
how many mates can we construct in this
position um we're going to
let's go with rook takes b2 there it is
just a joy i'm a board
yeah she looks like i mean
you don't see an elite grand master like
this
uh just getting completely
uh decimated
i mean this is terrible so imagine rook
d1 show us some of those mates you were
referring to with like um knight takes
f3 right yeah uh
he didn't want to see it anymore the
game's over oh and look at that
a little bit of a hat tip no thank you
he smiled after resigning he was glad
to leave that game that was his best
move of the game
you know what it says great game by the
teenager
when they said what happened to you guys
he said well i lost the pawn
and i'm down upon i i
saw that pond well i just it's a
critical pawn i'm going to resign
because it's up upon him
yeah no that king in the middle of the
board what a game by jeffrey
again we may think that there's
something stronger that could have
happened but
the smart thing he did was play
practically he saw a position
where he said i don't see the wind let
me go for a position that i know is
dominant and he went with the rook v6
knight d4 take the bishop
take the e pawn your king is stuck in
the middle well judged from a practical
standpoint by
the youngster that you know this this
may be some blow
but he didn't see it we didn't see it
that's a really mature decision on the
part of the youngster
to just do what is necessary to win the
game and he ended up winning
in 21 moves so i don't know what else
might have been there
but 21 is pretty short we called that
opinion
i think he did pretty well in that game
i think so too
what what did you say that the viewers
could do they there's a hash
of they could just drop it in blitz
there is a hat
you want to chime in um and and give
your opinion on
the days play the games um anything you
want
and i'm sure you're right yeah that that
game's going to get a lot of reactions
i mean this tournament we've already
seen anyone can beat anyone right there
exactly there are um no weak points
so no the field is so strong
uh just checking in on coming into
today's game we thought that this game
was going to be deciding
who was uh going to be in first but it
turns out that both
lavon and pentella lost the
fourth round games and they're trying to
get back into shape here
don't really know what to make out of
this position it's kind of confusing
um now can we go to the magnus game yeah
you guys think
let's do it all right uh
did we mention that alireza and and
wesley drew
no we were two jeffrey game
i believe that game in 20 moves is over
and knocking as well wesley drew that
game
very quickly gone we were talking about
the youngsters
the youngsters are plus one this round
against their esteemed elders
so don't count them out just yet they
may be making a comeback
but very importantly from the point of
view of the standings wesley is now
in clear first as nepo lost his game
wesley got that point and magnus with a
win
can catch wesley but he's still far
from that at the moment and lavon and
pentala if either of them win their game
they could bounce back
and um get back into that tie for first
they started the day with
with a different effect on the line lot
on the line
that's right so two great games to
finish out this round
as we've got carlson dominguez underway
or dominguez carlson
and oronia vs harry krishna um
but yaz is excited about this game and i
can't blame him i was going to say all
game yeah
that it looked like a sicilian but then
i was like that's a pretty dumb comment
because there's a pawn on c6
now i can i can really say it yeah it's
not as sicily
um something like that yeah what is it
we're not 100
sure but i must say that lanier
is way wasted is strong he spent
two tempe to play h4h5
and move his bishop once more uh
this is not the scintillating attacking
kinds of moves
that i would want to have seen i don't
i'm not
that big a fan of what lanier is doing
now h6 kind of sets up for
you know some dark square um
to to to combat to fight over the dark
squares
h6 by well
another move i'm not really happy with
either when i look at the
bishop d3 i ask myself what is my bishop
doing on d3
i i mean it's just making room for a
rook
i i it's it's it's his next move yes if
you follow yeah let's get to the
position as he moved
you move down uh after this rook movie
now played f4 and i think he was
trying to put some pressure some
protection
to his pawn on e4 and then maybe hoping
one day to play e5
but i gotta say even that looks
extraordinary difficult to execute
matter of fact uh given
given a couple of moves well the move
rookie 8 is really specific in attacking
the pawn but also it weakens the f7 pawn
but if you don't chase my f7 pawn with
the move bishop to c4
what moves would you play as white here
would you play for knight d2 knight c4
knight d29 f3 i guess i'm answering my
own question try to bring the knight in
but i have to be really careful that
you're not gonna push something
some pawn on the other side just when i
start this to try to open up lines
and it does look as though black has the
flexibility on that side
to make a move like a b3 wow b3 actually
just stopped me in my tracks
what are you doing yeah no b3 uh
there was a marvelous marvelous game
from uh lanares way back in the day
and it was um
um mickey mickey adams was on the white
side
of an open sicilian a night orf and
gary kasparov in the night or from like
mickey went g4 g5
g6 g takes f7 uh opening up the g
file and gary put a bishop on f6
and won an absolutely beautiful
beautiful game as black
the bishop on f6 is simply the
monster defensive piece monstrously
defensive piece and i'm thinking that
what you were saying about the knight on
b1 maurice you could go to d2 and f3 i'm
thinking
of c3 as white so if i could get a
situation where
i could aspire to eliminate this
knight now having knight f5 is always in
the air right
well to begin with but also having said
that i've opened up the d
the b file against myself lanier has
played bishop
takes d4 by the way that's this was a
concrete threat knight takes f5 was a
concrete threat
as well and he's given up his bishop
for this reason which looks which looks
specific
now that i look at it because you want
to play the move
bishop takes d4 you don't want to shut
down your bishop because you want to
keep the bishop
for the attack and potentially for the
defense
but this move does allow a potential e5
that you have to calculate right i'm not
sure what's happening after bishop takes
rook takes but
there's a threat now on the g7 square
potential for an f6 if you could get
your queen on e4
i can't see it working at the moment
just yet
as f6 is met by by captures
and queen e4 would be met oh maybe queen
e4 yes maybe queen e4 instead
as ben larson might say a knight on f8
uh i i don't get mated
i'm not trying to mate you actually i
mean i'm lying i would love to
but maurice this is like a first
maurice i'm not i'm not trying to check
me i'm just
i'm all about pawns right maurice and
ellie
i hope you didn't pay attention to it
but no i assumed you would stop
the mate is my point because you would
not notice
to me and my deeper purpose is to
create a position where i play the move
e6 and make you
uh sit on this piece because now i've
only given up an exchange i'm not down a
rook i'm just not an exchange
and i'm hoping that now i can use
the the very nice point on e6 and say
yeah you're stuck
and i'm going to put something by the
way magnus said
you're right you're right maurice i
don't want to
allow the move e4 e5 i'm going to
keep my bishop on f6 uh reluctantly or
otherwise he did take with the pawn
we've got
knight d2 knight c5 knight c4
on the board bishops of opposite colors
suddenly
it's well
whose ball game is it anyway what do you
think jen do you
do you like black lives matter all day
look at that
all day the progress we've made unless
you have like some very specific attack
tactic involving e5 it's like i feel
like you have like one
idea and black has a lot of ideas that's
the problem like if e5 has to work
that's it
that doesn't work you just you're gonna
lose a game so that's not good that's
not good when you're playing against
magnus and he knows
exactly what your intentions are okay
now the typical response to b3 is
capture with a c
pawn like every sicilian player with the
white piece's nose
take with the c pawn and then play a3
and then dare the guy to figure out how
to attack you because you blockaded that
side
now players with black have figured out
how to sack on a3 somehow
just anyway anyhow somehow they figure
out how to do that
in this specific position though the
knight is
under threat and this could cause
a tremendous amount of embarrassment so
that's why lanier
has started with the move king to b1
and trust me he wants to take that pawn
on b3
yes he wants to he wants to play this
move a3 but the thing about a3 is that
you open up the b line you give white
you give
black the ability to take on c2 and open
the b line so he
black keeps an avenue of attack if you
can use that pawn
as your spy right pawn takes on b3
and make the black pawn stand in the way
then you can get away with a3
so i think that's the threat is to take
and play a3 and say how do you
ever get at me and now it's my turn to
try to figure out how do i ever get a u
with the move e5
and get it so so to clarify for our
viewers
if i make a very bad move like rook e7
you're saying that strategically
this is where linear is aiming
this is the kind of setup he wants yes
right so he kind of shuts down the b
file shuts down the a file and hopes
that his
king will find a safety on the b1
square so and by the way note that e5
is a real threat i'm starting to wonder
about this thor
of the bishop on f6 because e5
that square is not protected
you can often times sacrifice with the
the
exchange um to keep that beautiful
bishop and try to limit your ideas
good points very good i mean that's
where suddenly maybe you can do some
kind of fun stuff like f6 and queen e4
but that that's a fantasy bla white's
got pressing problems here
magnus captured on c2 right i was about
to say is there anything to do
with just the simple i i like
that the the point you were making
maurice which was to play
to take on b3 play a3 shut things down
on the
green side since black doesn't want that
to happen
why not take on c2 and play rook b8 and
say okay
i've got a very concrete idea as well
which is to play
d3 and bishop takes b2
and and lanier said i don't want to see
d4d3
and he's just played the move bishop d3
that's a wise move if it works shut down
the play on the light squares shut down
and play on the dark squares by
re-emphasizing your control of the light
squares
and this is saying what are you going to
do if you ever play a3 i'm going to play
well i might think about taking it i'm
going to have to take it actually
because i don't want to play b3 and you
sack on me
no i'm really not a big fan of this move
bishop d3
at all i'm starting to look at okay let
me just
i'm starting to look at rook b4 and rook
b8
ideas let me play queen c7 so i i'm
setting up the pretty obvious
takes and takes but what i really want
to do is make
room for rook b8 and rook
sorry rook b4 with b8 so what are you
going to do about
queen c7 all right so nike 3 is a threat
big time yeah that is that's a good move
and knight d6 knight d6
e5 if you take i was going to recapture
with the queen
yeah that looks pretty good for you i
mean that knight on c5
is definitely dominant over the bishop
on d3 with those pawns on the king side
that are not going anywhere
that really present the challenge he's
playing rook b4 by the way
rook b4 and a3 occurred instantly
by the way in the other game i don't
want to move to it because it's not as
um as thrilling as this one but lavon is
up upon
he's off a pawn and they have only a
little bit over a minute each laugh so
he might be trying to
to regain his lead than he started today
with
so what did magnus what did magnus plan
here if he put his rook on b4
yeah i i thought that uh queen c7 is a
prelude to rook b4 but rook b4
also sets up knight takes d3 and that's
why we saw
a3 i'm assuming that he wanted
wants to play rook b3 chase that bishop
backwards back to c2 to attack you and
then and then
drop back maybe to b5 i
i really want to keep the idea of
of d3 and rook v8 and queen c7 all alive
he had five played rook b3 he did play
rook b3
and then bishop c2 was almost
instantaneous and then rook b8
also instantly guys keep in mind 30
seconds left for linear a little over
two minutes for magnus
this is not going to be a position that
they are going to calculate to the end
and figure out the perfect moves it's
going to be
a hustle now so e5 guys e5 looks like
the move that lanier has been avoiding
all this time
and and what takes is your idea jim
which i think makes perfect sense
i would love to play something as white
like f6 and queen e4 but that knight on
c5
protects the money squares right maybe i
could get my queen to f5
though you know but hold on look the
main issue is this
if you're up in exchange right for a
pawn
you don't have to mate white i'm not
made black you don't have to do that you
just have to make sure
that black doesn't mate you and this is
appearing in the board
rookie 5 bishop e5 this position is now
alive
15 seconds left for dominguez so what
about a move like bishop d3
here consolidate as much as you can and
say to
and he has played bishop d3 and say to
black
how do you beat me your knight on c5 is
a nice
attractive piece but it has nowhere to
go it just
you know white is black has just
retreated what if i bring my rook to the
e file
and i think about maybe even doubling on
the e line
forget about that straight attack oh now
he's played queen to c2
really consoling the light squares and
i'm seeing this weird idea of doubling
on the e line and if i ever get rookie
eight
i have a queen g6 check when your king
goes
to h7 and mating with that idea so
fantasy variations lots of fantasies i
agree
if i could get the rook down to the the
back rank and then i dropped my queen on
g6
that's mate you take me with your pawn
and i made you so
you gotta have a dream no but the point
is
the point is black has to defend against
this because the rook
the rooks are going to go to the e line
and and play against
europe and play for this one thing i
don't see any attack on the king side
directly
it's got to be the open file and it's
got to be the work with the roof
the road right i should say uh we've
just seen the move queen c2 we saw it
i was going for queen v6 i i love the
knight on c5 actually i think that's a
great
great square i guess magnus wants to
keep the b3 square in reserve for his
rook i was thinking queen b6 but magnus
by
queen a5 and g2 instantly
rook g2 instantly defending
b2 laterally because i'm sure
linear pardon me uh opposite i'm sure
magnus would love to be
able to play rook to b3 followed by d3
to unleash this bishop
and 14 seconds
queen queen v5 hitting the work on g2
by the way um credit where credit's due
veneer has been playing
some great defense with uh 15 seconds on
the clock
and he's just played the move worked to
e2
uh can you smell an idea a fantasy
was that the check on e8 and the queen
gets to g6 fantasy
uh but what what's the story after whoa
the
the computer bar seven just went nuts
after this last move
because n e4 uh
the bishop from f6 his time pressure has
cost him the game
queen e4 trying to trade was a mistake
and now the
the piece the queen and the bishop
together are going to just rip that king
apart
why what's the move here so sad i mean
first of all
queen c5 check king d2 queen c2 king
yuan why am i
resigning oh bishop h4 bishop h42 at
some point
bishop h4 check immediately yeah and
then king after in your exact line and
then
you've been my both my rocks yep right
that's it both of the rocks king bag
bishop
bishop h4 there you go because you're
looking forward to
me right yep exactly what is it
exactly nomination by magnus carlson can
we go back to it
he won he won the game although we
actually
lebron are still playing levon and
pentala are still playing
what a beautiful shot after that mistake
we'll have to check it take a look at
that more closely
but lavonne has an extra knight for a
pawn
against harry krishna so he has to try
to keep
that pawn on the board notice that he's
tried to stop the move knight f1
right i mean he doesn't have to some of
the end games with two nights versus
upon or winning for wyatt right but
i remember we said remember we said
murderers row
all right four pentals feeling it he had
nepo to start
and now lavonne and guess who he has
next round
magnus
absolutely not all right so king c5 was
played okay um knight b5
that's a strange move because now after
king c4 or
king b4 guess what the knights
are connected which is not something you
want which is definitely not something
you want king f4 played now
and now the king is just going to go
back and forth
i think that's just a draw it's got a
he's got a positional draw
on the spot with king c4 because
whenever you go
king to d2 to release one of your
knights
then comes this nice move knight f1
exactly
exactly what a beautiful pendulum
easy that's why they call them the
superfluous knights or
the codependent knights but i think in
this case it's the codependent knights
yeah right now they're not doing a good
job they're not doing a good job
also knight f1 would have been a
perfectly good as well as king c4 but
this is easy now uh for
uh i think they've actually been
repeating
so as soon as this game is a draw um we
can find out
um what the story will be it'll be uh
magnus
tied with uh wesley wesley right
magnus and wesley at the top a draw has
been agreed but
if you don't mind i just got to go back
to that moment
where it was just sort of like queen e4
you're right the computer bar went crazy
and
if you had this position you you kind of
want to
play queen e4 but on the other hand
you've got to be
so uh larry of
opening up the bishop queen e4 talk
about
spotting opportunity and you know
this is such an easy move to miss right
you could
you you could move your queen and you
would think about well maybe i'll take
this rook
i'll take this bond but to spot rook
takes b2
and it's it's a gorgeous it's a gorgeous
finish i mean
let's go through all the lines so king
b2 d3 check was the concept and now
we're we're forced to go king c1 we
don't have any other moves really
right because king king king c1
also walks into queen b3 which is kind
of true
so king c1 queen c5 check
king 2 okay so wait so we now what
happens if you go
back to king b1 now what happens if we
go back to king b1
okay uh could i go
check and take the rook uh just the
simple
simple chest just take that and then um
if i try to save myself with something
like rook e1 you have
queen b2 mating and rook v2
rook d2 um would allow
uh let's see i can doesn't look good i'm
like
yeah i got bishop g5 on tap
you could just you could just allow that
yeah yeah
yeah don't i get to the back crank here
with queen c5 check
that looks that looks good that looks
good yeah because actually
i had second thoughts about f6 maybe you
don't want to allow that
so yeah queen c5 looks like a better
move so
that's outstanding to calculate this i
know
it really is and and it was
it was when they were in time pressure
too but this gorgeous finish with bishop
h4
wow i mean you know
when magnus gets to write his book
you know my best games it's going to be
a trilogy and they're going to be 700
pages thick
what's our standings jen well we've got
co-leaders once again every everything
we've had two people at the top of the
leaderboard and
it's never been the same two people and
new leaders every time
the pattern holds as wesley so and
magnus carlsen are tied for the lead
with three chasers um and they are yano
ponnichi
lavon aronian and harry krishna all with
six points
um will the lead change hands once again
or will who be a soul leader
at the end of day two by the way could
we go back to that position very quickly
just the finish because there
it's there's more to it please okay
there's more to it right
here's because you mean king f1 queen
queen d1 and then this is where i
stopped yeah
yeah king f1 queen d1
rook e1 forced yeah we're saying you're
winning both rooks but you're actually
just
getting back your material so bishop
takes on e1
okay but now you've got
yeah you don't want that and and this f6
is coming
exactly so so let's see he could have
played
rookie one and said
okay let's oops true good point
so is it is it because you can trade off
all the pieces and play g6
and the queen of course yes
because that's the only other lineup to
play for so queen takes
takes takes and then
in this position your your d-pawn is
going to drop
but g6 is going to highlight the h-pawn
strength
and this is the problem and that's how
now you're winning
now you're winning uh as we go on that's
a lie
by the way that's a lot you don't you
don't calculate that immediately
your instincts take over there you just
yeah mean i think he saw a lot of lines
that just seemed like they were a
minimum perpetual but probably winning
um but it's absolutely extraordinary
like that tactical alertness
queen e4 work takes b2 beautifully done
by the world champion
and and as we go on our break we've got
a
a special uh for our viewers
as we ask the players uh
how do they stay in shape for this
competition during the lockdown
what has life been like for you since
the lockdown
and how do you stay in shape to compete
yeah i think i
uh how to say
degradated during the lockdown clearly
i mean i think i'm playing much worse
than i
used to before that as a professional
chess player
uh there are a lot less tournaments and
there's
a lot less competitions there actually
no serious competition because i
consider
classical chess to be the serious chess
right to be the big one
so a lot of things have changed there's
a lot less chess
but at the same time everybody in the
world is affected
so it's not an ideal year i mean life
has been pretty good these days i stream
primarily
every day so um i just stay stay sharp
with chest via
tactics or playing as other top players
who are online so
um in general just just a mix of
everything but just
keep it casual but we're always staying
sharp yeah and it's not
easy sometimes i just miss the
over the board tournaments and games
just moving the
wood pieces but
yeah it's not easy of course but i'm
training i'm
keeping up to date um
and yeah it goes nothing it is not easy
but
fortunately there are some online
tournaments that keep me
a bit busy well it's been a bit strange
of course
uh i've been trying to
to keep in shape like trying to
do some training i haven't played so
much
so i played couple of tournaments online
nations cup and then i played the
the clutch matches and then i played
this tournament in the
leon masters yeah i analyze things i
try to solve tactics every day i try to
stay
active just you know physically active
so i go for a run now and then i
play some basketball so i mean it's i'm
right now i'm in berlin
so it's pretty relaxed here
well i don't really think i'm i'm
staying in it just shape it's very it's
actually very special because i really
miss
those let's say otb tournaments uh like
however i think the
atmosphere you know the chatting between
players uh
in between or during games and uh you
don't really feel your opponent when you
only see only see him on zoo
so this is like very different at the
beginning it was quite uh
tough for me to uh to see that uh
event after event uh getting con uh
canceled uh and unable to travel
and uh you know for chess player this is
uh
this is like a torture my main source of
training since since lockedtown has been
playing tournaments
there's been a lot of them
and i would say for for such a format of
playing online and playing rapid chess
i should be in good shape fortunately
there have been many online events that
i've been able to participate so in
terms of playing and finding
tournaments it's been better than i
could have hoped for
and in the same way i i've used those
events to uh stay in shape
and uh i'm always working on other areas
of the game primarily the opening
um to to to make sure that
i'm ready when uh when the tournaments
come back
hello and welcome back to the st louis
rapid in blitz and guys
i actually think that that was the best
round yet i mean
i was on the edge of my seat the whole
round jeffrey's win i mean
jeffrey's win and magnus's win were in
the same round and it feels like it was
two different rounds but it was so
action-packed
um indeed uh the teenager jeffrey zhang
truly impressed but he's still
languishing on the bottom half of the
score table
um although he did get a little bit of a
bump but the big story is
magnus carlson back in the lead a
troubling event after that disconnect on
day one but
he is already back and in a tie for
purse with wesley sal
and uh for me it was really impressive
that magnus said
like i'm gonna target you lanier with
the black pieces i'm gonna play a real
challenging
game but look at this we've gotta move
on uh round five
is over everybody look at the pairings
for round six jen
yeah in just a few minutes we're gonna
get the beast pairing started
um the magnus playing against harry
krishna wow
um and emboldened jeffrey young against
levon aronian
naca versus nepo huge battle there guys
um that's a goodie yeah and wesley so
our tournament co-leader versus sasha
yeah i mean i love that
pairing too i i don't really know where
to go i mean obviously our co-leaders
playing with the white pieces
um is is definitely fun games to watch
because if either of them win and
they're the only ones to win
they go into day three with the solely
those are the two games those got to be
the critical two games although i think
carver and
nepo we're gonna have to keep our eye on
as well
as we do with all the games but just
early on to keep our eye on the two
leaders
magnus has shown himself to be
remarkable
so far in this event you think about it
he's disconnected
i mean he disconnected in one game but
look who he's beaten look at this guy
he's just
smiling and laughing and happy we saw
him relax at the top of the day
as though he had already digested the
thing from yesterday no biggie
it happens let's move on uh
he beat naca
right he's beaten aronian
right he's like he's taking them down
one by one like
you're you put somebody in front of me
knock okay no problem
and the game that he that he really kind
of had a little something and the nepo
really challenged him
is the is the disconnect game right
other than that
this guy he just does it again and again
and again it's an
easy person to pick to win the
tournament
i wonder who picked him by the way
that's just
i'm pulling a yellow serum well
i must say day two has been very very
favorable indeed for magnus he's come
he came into today just as you said you
know uh relishing the chance to get over
the disconnect game he had two whites
he started with a very nice victory
and then suddenly this game
i see that game that he just played as
some kind of a massive turnaround game
because i gotta tell you that after that
knight f5
i just didn't like h4 h5 follow-up by
lanier
but it sure felt to me like white was
pressing big time there uh but magnus
turned it around what can i say he's
just
he's he's he's playing he almost feels
like he's playing
in a league of his own right i mean
ikaru really is
the guy who's challenging him in these
remote tournaments
you know it's a big point when someone
is playing against
a player they feel they're better than
or shouldn't
compete on the same level
you know he sees a car where he might be
a little bit more circumspect
he sees a nepo okay you might see lanier
and say i think this is the guy i can
play an opening that may not be
the best but he might not handle it the
best way either
right and then if i have to i'll take
some chances
you know i'll just push those pawns on
the queen side
the assassiron positional player
understands you can't just get away with
that stuff
i'm gonna play knight at five i'm gonna
try to squeeze you
but lanier who's who's shown the
penchant for getting behind on the clock
and not necessarily playing up to his
his best play and then he gets into the
time pressure
and in the the final position the the
position where he plays this queen e4
he should be okay i mean he's blockading
that d-pawn
that bishop cannot be allowed to come
into the game
and then he makes that slip queen e4 and
that was it
like the first slip you make is your
last your the guy's not missing it he's
going to hit you
and you're going to go down so it's
interesting to see how magnus will play
very aggressively against her super
aggressive style take some chances
because he wants to win and you better
prove that you can hang with him
on every single move yeah always a
challenge of course and there he is
i mean jen what can you say this guy is
on
a streak that
really defies all odds he seems to be
playing at a 3000
tpr virtually every tournament
and uh when he does slip up
well somehow he quickly writes the ship
as well
yeah i mean the thing about online chess
is i think one of the reasons it
benefits
a player like magnus carlson is basic
math there's
online chess you don't have to travel
there's more time for more games
and the more games there are the better
it is for magnets
for the higher rated players a larger
sample size is always going to benefit
the
bit better player we we see that in
poker we talk we talk about getting in
volume
well in online chats it's easy to get in
volume you'll even see that
the schedules online are a little bit
faster paced
even with the same time controls that's
because you don't have to physically
reset a board and you know
have the players physically move away
and you know
um get a new get a drink of water
everything is is just crunched a little
bit which benefits a player
who wants to get in more games and
that's why you know maurice's pick
was really a great one because even
though magnus had an even score going
into the beginning of the day
there's so many games left
and by the way could we make this big
point
there are four rapid games left the
field cannot afford to for magnus to
keep winning
just exactly they're two points for
every single game
you might be a monster of blitz like
hikaru is but magnus is pretty decent at
blitz himself
so you if you're a karu for example who
wants to make
a run at some point you see yourself two
points behind magnus
you don't you can't afford for magnets
to win this game and you only draw
that's going to be three points and
every every win you have
at blitz is only one point each right
you cannot let this guy start
racking up points and by the way magnus
has three games tomorrow to get another
six points so people have to keep pace
with him
right now he's just won two in a row and
he's looking for a third
and you know when he's when that magnus
strange star train starts rolling down
that hill
it's like slow this guy down somebody
stop him please so this is a
very big game right now for the entire
tournament as far as i'm concerned
if he gets his confidence the way he
does forget it tomorrow he comes in and
racks up some more points
and we'll know the winner before we even
start the blitz
but look at this it stumped him yes
now we have been seeing a lot of d4 d5
e5 bishop f5
advanced variations including magnus
playing the black site himself
but you're absolutely right magmas kind
of stopped
and said okay do i want to play the
advance but this time he comes up with a
short defense
nigel short line with knight f3 bishop
e2
and very quickly hari krishna has played
c5 castles uh normally speaking
knight e7 knight c6 uh
is my favorite treatment uh knight c6
queen b6 is also
very very very well known um
there's in heavy theoretical water c2 c3
this was played against me in my match
with boris baskey
c2 c3 i didn't take immediately on d4
but this seems to be the the latest and
greatest of
in theories uh these days uh knight
takes 97.
so it seems like everybody knows this
position
uh just like everybody knows the initial
position
that's nice how far can you go right
right how far how deeply have you
studied it
do you write the nuances and will you
know when the new move shows up
how to handle it so this one is
interesting the other game we're keeping
our eye on is the one with
hikaru and nepo i believe or was it
wesley was it the wesley game we were
trying to
well let's just keep the leaders yeah
okay
so this uh queen's gambit declined with
the bishop f4
again this was was very challenging in
london world championship match uh
magnus carlson white fabiano cariwanna
black in a number of games knight d7
um c7 c5 is
the main move knight d7 does give
white the opportunity to try to clamp
down not what wesley did wesley went for
bishop e2 so they're still in the
opening
back to yeah that was my question
right here after 97
knight takes f5 knight takes f5 it looks
like a great french defense for black
right i mean there's a missing bishop
and there's a missing knight
but now having said that after the move
bishop to d3
you can't take the pawn bishop knight
takes bishop takes and oops
uh i walked into it a killer pin
so uh after bishop d3
the tala had to play g7 g6 refortifying
the knight and preparing to take the
pawn now but i
now i have uh the time for rookie one
and it
it's kind of funny on the one hand
strategically black is very happy
he traded off his bishop on the other
hand white has a very free and easy game
in this position queen e2
okay that's a little surprise move queen
e2
why is that surprising to you guys you
just feel like work is a much more
natural defender of the pawn yes exactly
okay now there's no choice i have to
play f4 right
i'm sorry jen you were about yeah i was
wondering if maybe he wanted to keep the
rook on f1
thinking that after f4 perhaps that work
could come in handy
unlikely but okay um
f4 i'm assuming this knight is going to
quickly swing
from b1 to f3 and maybe
um black will try to uh
break open the center with f7 f6
uh you were measuring maybe if they play
f6 we can play like knight f3 and we
don't have to worry about
i mean i know normally you would take on
f6
perhaps i'm just i'm still trying to
make sense of what you were saying about
why the queen and not the rook and here
that work at least protects the uh the
open f file
i don't know this does look like a model
french position doesn't it like the
thing about the princess
yeah yeah not really i know this wasn't
a french this was a caro but
in this structure you don't usually want
to take it with a pawn because
now all your pieces are kind of bottled
in right
and the e5 pawn could be yeah
really targeted by black's miners so i
think you're
if we do see f7 f6 i think it's almost
required that uh white take it now yeah
if he does take it queen takes
knight f3 you do have the two bishops
it feels a little bit more comfortable
for white
but it's it's
you prefer playing here because you are
a caro con player do you
do you prefer playing black here like
not like who do you think is better but
who would you rather be
i feel it's easier to play white because
even after i get in the desirable e5 i
haven't
completely and fully equalized i like
the two bishops
um
the jury's still a little bit out for me
um
i would say it's just kind of an even
position
by the way for although i think it's
easy to play white sorry maurice please
it's going to look very familiar the
position
between between dominguez
and alerisa farouzia
yeah this is like uh ikaru nakamura
versus magnus carlsen
but wasn't that with a rook on d1 and a
knight
was on b6 if i remember correctly where
the capture on where the capture on c4
was met by queen b1 so
some real differences i think it's
because magnus
no they took on because i think it was
like 97 bishop here
or no there was a rook on d1 for sure
right but there's a bishop on e7 right
the bishop was on g5
the white bishop was on g5 in the bit
yeah no it went like knight d7
rook here night here there was somehow
like i don't know how did we get it
remember
yeah no he played c5 at some point
and after but but
i think i think your rook is misplaced i
forget the exact position because
remember he played queen b1 but the a
rook was on d1 not the f
no because the knight went to f1 and to
g3
uh maurice in that game right i agree
okay we're going to have to go find the
game
set our memory but this pawn structure
we do know is exactly the same
exactly that at least we know and this
c5 break was happened very early
and after takes on c5 if you play the
move c5
and the guy takes it you would assume
that you knew your next move yeah well i
think it's pretty straightforward that
he
does intend to play knight uh
to d7 and recapture with a gain of tempo
the queen
you know is very attractive target in
the center of the board
so why did he why is he waiting so long
then he played c5
is he shocked his opponent allowed
his next move with dc5 maybe he
didn't think takes on c5 was the was the
best move
by the way he's sporting the same
colorful shirt jen
that you liked uh on day one yeah it's a
great shirt
that is great uh he took on c5 and
you're right i
would have thought that he's you know
really really ready
let's quickly just check in on the game
between ikaru
and yan okay as we expected
both these players played very quickly
looks like a morocci
vine kind of a position with a missing
dark square bishop
for white not good you want that white
light dark squared bishop right ooh but
check this out
uh f5 bishop takes f5 oh
precisely did hikaru
blunder a poem yes yes you know why i
know
why because i'm looking at your cards
it just goes to show you at all levels
you know you know you tell
kids or adult beginners um
that you gotta watch for those loose
pieces but hey that applies to the best
players in the world too
you still have to look for those loose
pieces even when you reach
a rating of over 2 800 as you see
nakamura has here in the universal
rating system
but you know you're absolutely right jen
you should always be
aware of loose pieces but when you look
at white's position
and you look at this knight on b3 you're
not you're
you're kind of at this awareness yeah
yeah yeah it's not defended
but at the same time you're surrounded
thinking to yourself nobody can possibly
attack the knight on v3
oh this is so cool i get to trap the
bishop
on e6 this must be fantastico for me
until you go there there
oops the knight on b3 is suddenly
hanging
in this position nakamura has played the
move c5
quick question yes what about like what
was nakamura's idea
with f5 like for instance if i played
knight takes b6 first why would that
have been bad
so if i played knight takes b6 first
then
the same thing he was thinking that now
the knight would have to move let's say
to c8
right and then you'd get to expose my
king with e takes f7 jack and daddy and
maybe
bad things start yeah hold on hold on
stop
stop please i don't understand the
knight is not under attack right
i know that's the whole point he could
have still taken on
e6 and said yeah you still can't take me
right
so are you sure though takes on f8
because there's takes on f8 i mean you
can't take with the queen is that a
problem
right that's the question suppose we
take with the bishop
because if you take with the bishop you
do allow
knight d4 hold on can we you're done
you're done you're going to be down a
piece so let's just at least look at
this line
no i'm taking the b6 knight i'm taking
the b6 thing because i'm going to be
able to move my knight ah right because
now queen v6 there's the bishop was on
g7 before
right but the problem is you you do have
an e5
yeah or b two seven and then g7 and then
it's the same so that's what that that's
just the thing you you would have to
look at and also is there another move
queen d4 after takes
what about queen d4 well no i'm taking
i'm taking the night yeah sorry i'm
taking the night
and now bishop g4 your idea
yeah bishop g7 well you do have bishop
g7
and you're still in the game blacks up
pawns right
up on a pawn yeah when you take on e6
it's going to be one pawn but
you know my bishop on g7 is also going
to be beautifully well placed but okay
the reason i wanted to ask about this
variation is true this gives us some
insight also into why
your might have missed it because there
was actually a lot of variations to look
at with pawn takes e6 as well right
right and you're kind of feeling uh like
you're
you're running downhill a little bit
there for white
so that was why f5 looked very
attractive but now after c5
and the threat of course is to take the
knight in either way
so now knight c8 nyan says
excuse me but i'm a pawn up and
this bishop is an absolutely
absolutely fantastic piece i love
black's position
i think that if i could get these types
of positions with black
i would never deviate from this opening
choice very very nice
uh quickly quickly uh take a look at
wesley's
no stay away from this game just kidding
you're gonna get it looks a little bit
boring
back to magnus for a second well yeah to
be fair the wesley game it could
uh it's just there's so many other
interesting games and that one does look
rather balanced right
i mean whether it's a flight pool with
the uh
the bishop versus knights but jen just
admit it
even if it was the only game we wouldn't
want to look at it
it wasn't that great okay it's not going
to end and rook takes b2
like magnus's game no it's always the
killer blow
in jeffrey's game that ended the game
also rick takes b2
oh wild you're right i didn't notice
good catch
good catch rook b2 was the power move of
that round
ended ended well jeff jeffries wrote me
two was tougher though because
uh it just ended life me too the guy
didn't want to make another move
no of course magnus's shot was superb to
find it in that moment it was clearly
superb so i'm being facetious
but uh we just saw this move
queen d8 by hari krishna as he's
eyeballing queen
uh beef six check also it's like the
queen
you know in these kinds of positions the
queen somehow just not very good on
f6 it blocks the bishop and
there are a lot of times that you
actually want to
attack the pawn on f4 you want to play
let me just put a move on the board
you want to sometimes play moves like
knight d6
knight e4 bishop h6 and the queen on f6
is just kind of in in the way i like
this move a lot
by um hari krishna
to play queen d8 put the queen maybe on
c7 d6 or b6
and by the way at certain moment if
you're not
if you're if you're willing to allow e6
e5 uh if it works out tactically
black is just fine so uh by the way
magnus playing very slowly jen
uh what's the time differential almost
three to two
nice seven and a half minutes down on
the clock
at the moment is magnus as he's trying
to
get this end of this position yeah a
little bit of a struggle for
for magnificent it's not easy you you
have on the analysis board king h1 his
king is actually still on g1
excuse me and he's trying to figure out
what to do
to make this position go from a to b
because
you look at it it's really not easy to
figure out what white's
plan should be here yeah the ideal setup
you know what is the setup
right it's i just i want to play maybe
b3 and put the bishop on a3 but that
looks
ridiculous first i'm dropping the c pawn
but also the f pawn to come under fire
so that's a challenge queen b6
is coming as well uh
i i don't know what to do with white i
just
don't know actually what to do i'm very
curious to see what magnus comes up with
king h1 looks like it makes sense but
then what do you do
what are your next three moves how do
you improve this position from here
i'm thinking that if i'm white on a good
day i would like to play bishop d2
bishop takes c6 knight
to e5 and rook on a1 to
e1 so i'm thinking some kind of a
combination of those moves where
i develop my rook to e1 and i put my
knight on e5
would be what i think magnus wants to do
um another
no i don't
another consideration is like these
bishops of opposite color middle game
positions if i
if i play something like this right i'm
just putting some
uh moves on the board these bishops of
opposite color middle games right
um now i can't make an argument that
this could be it looks like
an end game also yeah more things are
coming up
yeah no i i i don't have
an alternative besides d2
you know what i'm scared of two years
but i'm scared of is you
putting a knight on e4 black i mean
putting a knight on e4
right because if for example your bishop
d2
yeah really i much prefer king h1 just
getting the king and now you were about
to say knight 96 yeah
96 and you probably
don't want to trade because of knight d4
if you trade i mean 94 is going to
happen
at some point and even if you if you
put your knight on e5 i want to play
knight e4 and then take your knight on
e5
this would be my my desire right right
i want to be able to get rid of your
strong piece
for my piece i don't i know my bishop
looks good but
your bishop is not going to do anything
and my knight will be a forever piece on
e4
and i'll play around this piece just to
put the kind
so that the viewers can catch up with
your concept
is that what you're saying is the knight
on e4 is
literally unassailable right it's like
one of those
knights that's really really great
whereas this bishop
on e3 might become a septic
uh bishop with literally nothing to do
and the pawn on e4
e5 is hanging although even here i
actually when you play queen c7
you you made it clear that i actually
didn't even have to take this knight i
could just put the knight on e4
i was thinking i was going to take on c6
no i understand and that's why
that's why it's why your move is good so
you you played a natural move we see
seven
and that move makes sense because now
when you play bishop e3 i can just play
94 without even having to play bishop
takes nine
ah so i'm agreeing with with this
sequence and saying just
why not just put the knight on e4
the reason i was trying to get rid of it
is so you never challenge my knight on
e4 which is great
it would take a lot of time for you to
do by the way we've been in this
discussion
deeply for quite some time magnus has
been in thought
deeply for all this time while we've
been talking
and still hasn't come up with a move he
is down
what did we have it before seven and a
half minutes yeah now he's down
over 11 minutes and finally he has come
up with your move bishop d2
that you mentioned quite a while ago by
the way well
if you've got nothing else to do king h1
bishop d2
by the way i think we started at a three
to two
time advantage for pentala but at the
end of the move it became greater than
two to one
uh quite a lot of time but now having
said that the position
pretty simplified so i don't think it's
a factor yet
but it's it's about to be a factor uh
jen this time can
this uh time differential was really
great
yeah but we know magnus um playing moves
like rook takes v2 with very little time
on the clock
wow um that that said yeah i mean i i
always struggle when i get these
structures
with white i mean a lot of times it's
with a pawn on f2 so it's a bit
different
but i find that like when i used to play
the trash variation
of the um french defense just i
it was kind of a little difficult to
figure out what to do which was funny
because earlier you said you thought it
was easier to play for white but
um obviously you play the carol khan
with black so you have probably have
comfort with both colors
yeah um but i think a lot of people can
relate because
yeah it's there's a lot of supple
possibilities here for black
with these ideas of e5 and d4 and queen
b6
check and knight d6 was actually
relatively quickly
played by harry who really wants to
press this time advantage it seems
and now what do you predict do you think
he's going to move his bishop
back to d3 yeah
i think unfortunately he's kind of
obligated
uh to do that because the e4 square is
really um well that's a sensitive square
and if i trade the bishop as we've just
seen on c6
uh the problem is that i can't really
compete for the e4 square very well so
bishop d3
seems right now we kind of start to
understand why
i was saying the queen on f6 really kind
of gets in the way
uh there's a potential for uh
an attack on the f uh pawn with bishop
h6 but there's
also a potential for like this and this
is the type of thing now if there was a
queen on f6
suddenly the rook on f1 is in business
here you know there is
uh a tempo for black against the queen
and there's
always queen b6 check ideas that you've
got to
calculate as well so and we do see
bishop d3 on the board
i was did magnus really take a minute
to play bishop d3 you got to be careful
wow by the way take a look at the
barn burner between hikaru and
jan and i think that something happened
on the way
to the grocery store because
look at this after we got to the
position after c5
knight to c8 and we were saying pawn up
but the knight on c8
does not cut an impressive figure rook a
d one
bishop to e5
queen f4 bishop to e5 sorry sorry yes
rook 81 queen eight
queen f4 bishop to e5 queen e4 queen c6
funny maneuvers going on queen e3 giving
a
second pawn on b2
bishop c4 and now d
takes on c5 a is that a third pawn
that's a third that's the third pawn
and now f takes g6 and you'd expect
h takes g6 to be played he has a queen
g6 which doesn't look likely
but he's right now down three pawns the
c5 pawn
i don't i mean knight takes c5 is
playable i'm not playing queen c5
and going for an end game but what's
happening here
naca looks much more perky right now
than he did before
and he's a little ahead on the clock but
why not that much
but it's three pawns at well at the
moment it's only two
but we know he's going to take back on
g6 what is the evaluation
white pieces look great hg6
has been played white's pieces look
fabulous
but he is two pawns down right
and but i'm afraid of the light square
attack when i don't ca tells me there's
going to be a light square attack
that if white can take advantage of it
then
could be issues uh for black
is there some kind of tactic on f7
exactly that's what i'm looking at
yeah i know i'm thinking rook f7
like rook f7 rook f7 rook d h
king g8 is there something here do i
have a nibble
queen queen queen uh
no no no can i go knight c5 and
by the way i saw a queen f2 in this line
hoping to pick off the bishop on b2
unfortunately there's both bishop f6 and
queen f6
dealing with that idea what about your
queen h6 move was that bishop g7 also
yeah that
yeah because ah yeah i was trying to
happen game after game
wait doesn't queen f4 pick off the rook
on v8
oh geez talk about blindness i do bishop
g7
queen f for no no before just
immediately there's like an f4
and where do you put your king no you
have to move your queen
probably well bishop f6 queen
takes uh do i how many pawns do
yeah back to the pawns again you do have
two you have two
yeah but now white black should i have
some attacking chances like
i guess you have to play like six to
save your knight and suppose i play rook
f8 or rook g8 and look at this the king
is like
somehow beautifully defended
in the middle of the board laughing
that's hilarious that's a very funny
c4 c3 c2 c1 on the works
and white's pieces are over without over
stretching
i want to go somewhere besides cafe but
it doesn't help what i really want to do
is like get a
check on g8 but i but 88 is covered by
the bishop
so this is a crazy position
but you have that same like my gosh
isn't
you know rook f7 on tap here but
whatever it is
you got to be quick because the knight
is coming to d6 does it make any sense
to toss in i don't know bishop d5
i'm assuming the queen has to go to c7
now you don't have that f4 check anymore
right
right exactly you still have bishop f6
to defend
against queen f2 check as well
and you also don't have the rogue d.a
check idea right
here knight d6 in that position these
these lines are so messy
um rook f7 queen e6 knight e6 and then
if rick takes d6
pawn takes d6 and the queen on c7 a hero
again
by the way knock his face naka's face is
going through gyrations as you are
showing those lines jen as you're saying
them it feels like
the frustration as you solve one move
followed by the next
naka is showing the frustration on his
face as he sees the moves
he's like he's like what oh no he's out
of there too with that
and there's another movie he's defending
with what's going on you can just see
naka senses
something here and yet every forcing
line is leading to
okay for black well it's like
you it really feels like there's
something but sorry jen i miss exactly
what you were saying
uh could you repeat yourself because
it's oh i was just showing the line
where you you were showing a line after
queen c7
bishop f7 rook f7 i mean sorry rook f
bishop f7 rook f7 queen e6 i was saying
knight d6 and then
rook takes d6 doesn't work because pawn
takes d6
and the queen beautifully defends
laterally
gotcha and then i guess you have to try
queen g6 instead
but um blacks have a whole rook so yeah
you're not gonna have to give up the
line there
uh does it make any sense the other way
uh recep takes that i mean work take
steps happen you mean
yeah i yeah rook no i i don't
try it come on we get to get you just
try the move right
and then play and then play a queen
attack
queen g6 yeah and now queen takes on g6
and
rook f1 can be met by rook f 8 or even
e5 and you're going to be up a piece
after
bishop takes up seven right now in the
end of the day
no upper rook oh yeah up a piece yeah
once you take on f7 yeah
exactly but can you can you move
though in this position like bishop e6
is what i want to do
that's the most ridiculous move i could
think of i just don't want you to push
i think this pond's coming home huh but
the knight is coming over to g5
i can bring my knight to swing all the
way over while you're sitting there i
know it's
ridiculous oh fascinating position
insane okay
oh what about 92 okay it's crazy i agree
it's it's a nutty idea crazy position
okay but
uh hikaru much like ourselves
is struggling to come up and he knows he
has to
hit now because if black gets to play
knight d6
and i don't even know maybe even e5 e6
or just simply
bishop d4 he'll consolidate and he'll be
better
so it's here there oh
no what guys
looks like magnus is gonna go 3-0 today
as ventala blundered in one move
oh literally in one move
oh he did play e5 by the way got e5 in
he got
all that stuff take a look takes takes
takes
all this he got queen knight beautiful
square on e4 bishop e3
and this move knight c5 rook f1
he can't hold his knight and the back
rank
at the same time queen c8
is going to be a problem queen c8 is
going to hit the knight on c5
right even if you play queen e7
queen c8 bishop fa we can take bishop f8
is playable
you could take on f8 right
and then yep and that's an easy winning
position so after rook f1
he got three oh oh no
now he's in the last position right you
know you needed your queen to
guard the back rank and the knight on c5
one
move one move knight c5
blunder and magnus is going to coast now
for hari krishna this was actually two
losses in just one draw and he was
i think he was losing against lavon we
just didn't get a chance to look at it
but it was two nights versus one night
remember and the night got stuck but i
think lavon
so for hari krishna of day two has just
been
horrendous a disaster and
have drawn their game so unfortunately
we can't analyze that
rook and two miners versus working two
miners maurice oh wait a minute
this is fascinating it's wrong here
he's already drawn lanier versus ali
uh risa farouja uh
okay that that's a good one that looks
like a crazy game what's going on here
okay you gotta like it the junior is
showing some moxie here
with this rook h6 uh rover
jet this one's amazing this what a sick
game
by the way 28 safest square
and by the way the queen is on b1 sorry
maurice please
hikaru finally made a very direct
move in his game well maybe he's not
totally direct he played queen 86 after
much thought queen h6
he's basically saying if you
play knight d6 he's he's it's like a
prophylactic move right a preventative
if you play knight d6 i can play queen
takes on g6 with
check because of the pin however
bishop g7 your bishop is hanging right
and you're um oh
mm-hmm yeah you know that's a well
that's a weird tactic i haven't seen so
you're saying bishop d5 queen d5 yeah
yeah old desperado but check this out if
he doesn't play knight d6
bishop f7 rook f7 rook v8 is a threat
so um like what
he's like four no but queen g bishop g7
is an option
bishop bishop okay
yeah if bishop g7 bishop f7 rook f7
rook d8 check you're still in some
difficulties because i have three rook
three majors all all lined up on the f8
square
like all of my tanks yeah that
that's quite convincing i agree with
that thanks
that's quite convincing so you cannot
buy korova
but you cannot play that way so that
means
knight d6 is necessary and he has
found the move knight d6 is on the board
what a tactic
i love this i love this okay so suppose
we don't play queen takes g6
um the problem is if you play
bishop yeah uh to t5
uh i tried to do the same thing as
before i want
to coax you to play queen takes g6 so i
can go
queen takes d5 and if wow what a move
that's wild and if i move my queen away
to like e3 oh not e3
uh well e3 sure whatever e3 then
he just moves his queen yeah and then i
i take c5 but
you're down three pawns at the moment
well
two now but right now now you're sort of
down two because a5 is
yeah yeah okay fair enough though two is
this is enough
knight d sat in there but you're right
two pawns is bad enough but
i mean i don't know what else does black
that's a extr
i mean this is really an extraordinary
line i i like this because queen takes
g6 is such an important tactic and
honestly usually when you get to play
queen takes g6
and they can't pretty good yeah you're
usually winning
naka has been showing some pained faces
look at him right now
he just he is not happy he sees that
this
the move does not work and look how calm
nepo looks right and look at the
toppings after queen g6 bishop g7
rook takes d6 just queen takes or yeah
queen takes and then bishop f7
yeah no queen h6 as a defense right
and then we're down we're just going to
be down in exchange
and we can't keep the juice in this
position like by sticking our queen on
g4 or something like that
nope you need to move like you're right
yeah with that kind of idea
you need to move like knight to east
knight to e6 in one move sometimes
superstar
give me two moves in a row
isn't that like traveling in the nba you
just can't travel
james harden dude dude travels on every
flag
96 would be so sweet today's nba they're
traveling all the time
if you talk about talk to the old guys
no this position
i think he has to play rook takes d6 uh
though
uh the reality is if black
you know bishop d5 queen takes d5
maybe white gets some drawing chances
but
i mean that's all play on one goal what
the heck just happened
he played knight d is that on the board
it's on the board that is inspired he
played
knight d4 look at look at nepo's eyes
look at nepo's eyes
but look at naka naka now is shaking his
head
i don't know if this is oh okay so
bishop d4 takes d4
right right with the idea brooke takes
that if you take on d4
now i've got the check there's no bishop
g7 i've got at least a draw
my perpetual maintenance even in there
yeah maybe a rook lift will give white
the wind so
you can't and if this would be for a
birthday for a night wow
but yes bishop d before
knight c4 there's rook h4 right so
that's a nice line
but look at what look at this isn't
something wrong
instantly instantly uh
queen e4 landed on the board
in response to knight d4 and rook at
four
but i'm seeing
isn't queen e3 and knight c4 winning on
the spot only there's a knight f5
possible whoa hold on i thought queen e3
check
king h1 okay and then just play knight
takes on c4
and i just thought that was winning
because the the rook is pinned you can't
move the rook
right but now knight f5
but how much are you giving up yeah gf5
rook d4 pawn
for exactly oh no i'm not even winning
anything a nice guardian
yeah the knights guard in the queen so
why doesn't this win
i think it does oh no wait what are we
oh and queen g5 is bishop g7
in that line queen g5 is bishop g7 and
you don't get anything
why doesn't queen e3 check just win on
the spot
i think it does h1 take the bishop
so there's no taking on f4 variations
anymore right yeah and your
only idea is knight f5 there's there's
no other item oh
yeah there's no other ideas there's
literally no other id in the position
actually i thought knight to b4 followed
up
queen e4 wow just again chess is not
checkers maurice said it earlier in the
in the broadcast you don't have to take
that knight on d4
and he played something else he played
queen f5
f4 and then decided to take on d4
and play wait really
this one so he's got a lot of pawns so
he's got two rooks for the queen
as well as um let's count them two pawns
one two three three actually right yes
you're right
and for the moment if we can hold on to
that d4 pawn it's not gonna be easy
because
f5 and b5 are both protected by the
bishop so you might get to take that
pawn off
but while you're doing that i'm going to
try to connect my rooks
and start checking you this is such a
wild position sorry i just have to
i mean i i i it may take me a while to
get the zen of it i'm really kind of
surprised
that jan so very quickly he had 12
minutes on his clock
queenie breaking news
magnus carlsen has won his third game in
a row
well we knew that was coming we knew
that wow in the clear lead as wesley so
um earlier um did score that draw
against alexander grisha
yeah once patella blundered blundered
his queen
that we knew that that was a wrap up
that was just magnus finishing the job
off properly
as we know he would as we knew he would
and
uh this move nasty bishop takes d5 of
queens
rook takes and simply queen c4 and
that's all she wrote yeah uh
pardon me yeah no uh
one move blunders and uh again
this game by hikaru has just been a
rock'em sock on craziness
i mean just an amazing game but queen e3
was winning no
queen e3 knight c4 you know
it it wouldn't surprise me that there
were other wins but
the one but what you showed uh
um maurice golly i was going to call you
yan there for a moment
yeah but you showed maurice look like
the cleanest
because eliminating that bishop and
putting a check on the board my goodness
um what do we have in st
what i don't i don't know what there's
just no
oh there's one idea there's one idea
here maybe
confuse them in this position rook
d3 is playable i thought only knight f5
existed
rook d3 try to get the queen away what
else can you do
put the king put the king on h2 by the
way so you don't have queen
one check put the king on h2 so you
don't have
right here uh after check you want to
put the king on a dark square oh that's
not going to be
i don't want to but i'm going to put it
there and now when you take now rook to
d3 and now you don't have a
check but you could take the rook
now and take the knight on d4 and then
that's a lot of food
right right can i i can do it this way
as well right
that looks yummy yeah that's a lot of
food that's a lot of food
it's a pizza it's over i think queen e3
was was more clean what he did in the
game let me go back to
the game position for just a second in
the game position we
are achieved yeah
actually this car just got in the movie
h5 and what's getting harrier and
harrier is h6
now could be played wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait you're gonna be
fourth
whoa whoa well it's black mode it is
black smoke yeah but latte
and put my rope oh i apologize
uh queen g um
footweight no no
i'm trying not to lose a rook i promise
i'm trying not to lose a rook so
check uh king and rook uh that's
that's a way i can't lose a look oh that
was the other
i was on the stream after yesterday's
show i went on the stream of
ikaru nakamura and he was showing like
his
longest game ever where he had two rooks
against a queen and some extra pawns
and it's ironic that uh he and he won it
with the rook
against the queens uh the rooks against
the queen
uh but it's ironic that uh he should
have that
in reverse now but sorry um
it's it's extraordinary though this is
not what jan had
compared to what he has it's not clean
he's just like
unbelievable now he has to actually look
at the but he did take on h5
he's still up the two rooks and two
pawns for the queen
but there's gonna be some i mean he he
looks confident that he can technically
do this and i don't
i don't doubt his skills but this is not
the cleanest
you know had all the food in in your
mouth and eating the guy's lunch for him
as well this one here is just going to
be
some kind of a little bit of technical
difficulty there is a game though that
when
we looked at way back when and it's
still
amazing given all these end games on the
board look at the game between lanier
and
alerisa a mess a mess
what is this this is an asset straight
up nuts
with only four minutes for dominguez
surprisingly he's ahead on the clock
over the youngster in this position
huh but wow it looks like
black no
no i i just love i love uh
in a french when i have a knight on f5
and the other guy
has a dark square bishop i'm like in a
zone now the queen on a6 is terrible the
knight on d6 is a challenge
uh check let me
let me trade off this night and open up
my queen
and play bishop versus knight
why did i have oh that was that was i
was four
i was uh whoa he took on h4
immediately okay i'm saying if you take
his
piece knight f3 check is coming and g2
is hanging at the moment
wait wait what's up with this this looks
uh
this looks reasonable g3
the quick move no thought to it allowing
a knight to
land on f3 with check if you want to
that
4 minutes and 23 seconds to 2
32 okay uh
this is one of those cure is worse than
the disease scenarios
because you your pawn was hanging
you felt the need to defend it you could
have moved the king for example
and that the rook couldn't capture on g2
king h1 after knight h4 yeah
not this position but the actual right
so knight h4 king h1
avoiding the the fork and rook g2 is not
playable because the knight is hanging
and knight g2
is not the end of the world yeah right
not desirable yeah your knight is a
little bit trapped there huh
and i i've got some right as well it's
so so it's a weird position
but he did what he did and now something
is dropping on the f3 square it looks
like the knight
from h4 has gone there as he's
eyeballing h5 right
h5h4 king
i'm expecting h4 now by
but man this rook on a1 makes a terrible
impression like what
h4 just looks natural and it's of course
just going after him
so this one still has a little bit of
ways to go even though they're in time
pressure
what is happening in ikaru's game
ikaro's game um
is rapidly simplifying as it's going to
be two works and three pawns versus the
queen
um rookie six was just played and you
can't anticipate that um
nepal will take the the pawn on f5
will capture f5 i'm sorry yeah we'll
take the pawn in f5 rather and
i mean does black have
reasonable winning chances here or is
that king too airy
like can i try to coordinate my rook
somehow to attack g2 twice
that's the biggest issue rook g6 or c2
yeah exactly
no queen takes h4 and not on tap because
of just rook h6
and that's no fun for naca who's having
played queen d8 and queen d7
after uh after rookie six he did not
capture on f5 he actually played
check on f
but he thought maybe queen d7 and he was
going to get
upon despite that but okay
now work f6 played
okay that work looks super awkward guys
but wait a minute you just you just let
black
keep an extra pawn like what i mean
awkward or not i mean you're
a moment ago you could have had this f5
fawn off the board
now it's just still on the board that's
great for
black i mean he's ready to go rook c6
and i don't know maybe f4 h3
ideas or f4 f3 ideas and expose
the white king and that's what he's done
uh relax winning chances just went
through the roof i think i i can't
understand
oh king h3 so hikaru is saying
i don't want the f5 pawn i want the h4
pawn
really really that was my question too
is that an error
judgment though because wow uh
i'm not sure you want that h4 pawn
frankly like let's say i play
um i mean i'm not trying to put my king
on h4 and never go back home
that's that just seems like a problem
like king h4 now
okay something like rook c3 or rogue g6
well well let's get the queen out of
here i mean the queen bothers me
king g7 has been played so let's see he
did take the pawn
whoa whoa this that can't be right
dangerous so many twists and turns guys
no what do you think is the king
is the king is in danger of getting
mated jen
yeah meeting that so what but what move
do you play right now are you going to
play
well let's say i play rook here so i'm
threatening to play
check and mate okay so let me check you
before you meet me
before you i mean maybe maybe i'll
revert to my plan of
trying to take on f5 but no then i think
you're going to win my queen
so if i if you move your king and i play
queen f5 you've got rook h6 rook g6 and
then you hit me with rick f6
so something like this is what you mean
yeah
oops i don't understand and we've got
a a result in the perugia game
the result in the farouzia game indeed
as um what linear one
what but linear won the game
lunar won the game on time i think
i think it must have been on time
because the final position does not
looks pretty wild but we'll get
confirmation on that
it does look like is low on time
so the story would check out more than
him resigning here
um he did not resign here but yeah we'll
have to find
out the details for you on that and um
meanwhile the only remaining game
right i like this move as a preparatory
to everything
rook e6 just kicked that queen out
and can't we set up this mating net that
we've been discussing
i know you guys are enamored by the
mating but i really wanted to play
rookie 4 rook g4 and then go for rook g6
he's played rookie two also going for a
mating net right if we take on g2 then
rick h6 will be made
if we sorry if we take on what well if
we if we are allowed to take on g2 then
work h6 oh yeah no he doesn't want to
give up that g2 pawn
that's this last sliver of hope on the
board you cannot give it up
by the way if you give up the pawn
forget the mate i'm going to play f4 f3
f2 f1
so and you can't let me take this pawn
so king g3 played
rook g6 check on the board now king f3
of course
rapidly quickly yeah
but what if we just take on g2 with the
g6 rook
that with the g6 rook that way you can't
take my f pawn because of check
mm-hmm yep the skier and if i start
checking you it's not going to be enough
to last too long
should it shouldn't last and he took it
the
way this was kind of my oh because he
has a rook after he has a rook f6
also he has rook at six that was the
point you can't take on f5 this way
because of rook f6
yep but uh but you do have a queen check
right queen e5 shack
clay king h7 okay now we're going to
take on that f5 you can't play rook f6
mm-hmm that's true and he's and that's
what happened uh oh
all right what is happening now this is
just so much work
work g3 check king e2 on um we're
working three checks on the board k2
hasn't been played yet um
right king g8 on the board yes i see
what
i see it man
nepo could have won a long time ago wow
talk about in this thing
i mean sometimes you feel like you can
really torture your opponent by
keep giving them these like droplets of
false hope right
like you're almost there you're almost
there you're
you're so close to the draw we can both
taste it i'm sorry
i'm still winning
queen c7 rookie six that mating net is
uh guys g6
old school ladder mate is threatened how
do you stop
it old school ladder oh
check the letter you check him and pray
and hope that he messes it up but ikaru
knows he's in trouble he's feeling the
stress
this could be his whole tournament
losing this game going four points
behind maggie's magnus that's rough
who's gone 3-0
and days uh we checked again
queen d3 check and again i find it so
ironic because yesterday's stream
hikaru was showing his game that went
forever two rooks versus the queen and
that is funny and now yeah he's right in
it and now king h6 work at five check
okay so the
we are ensnaring the king now that's it
and he didn't notice it and he resigned
because we're just
designing king
sorry my fault yes of course rook h5 and
that's game and nepo
finally won that game hikaru tumbling
terribly oh my gosh way out of
the standings at the moment but nepo
kudos to him to get that
big two points although his face is
showing he said
nah i shouldn't want that dramatic day
for
for nepo and he was always in some kind
of insane battle i mean he was also the
one on
on the wrong side against jeffrey chang
and we do have the leader in the
tournament
world champion magnus carlson is on the
line
after uh well first we'll see magnum
magnus can you hear us
magnus are you with us
looks like he's not quite hearing us yet
something has to be turned on
so apparently he wasn't watching our
brilliant analysis of this
uh nakamura shame on him shame on him
barely hear i can barely hear him though
uh i'll speak a little bit louder
do you hear him guys oh a little bit
i think i think he's trying to adjust
his microphone in front of
his desk making some adjustments when
you're ready
magnus let us know uh okay
okay but apparently i'm not oh there we
go
okay now we can now we heard something
very clearly
magnetic welcome back to the show
you know you had a really bad day today
i mean it was just awful
uh yeah i
i had a nice day obviously um
the first and third game were
sort of gifts i would say and uh
the second game was was
was a lot of fun so yeah great of course
after yesterday yesterday's hiccup with
the disconnect
you seemed very relaxed at the start of
the day today had you just put it behind
you
yeah um i was obviously very upset
yesterday
um like losing because of something
that's
a little bit out of my control so my
main
prep today was just uh
uh you know uh making sure
there were backups and backups and more
backups for
in terms of maths so you mentioned the
linear game being a lot of fun um of
course work takes b2
was sensational at what point did that
occur to you
um i i thought of the idea a little bit
before
um like
i hear after rookie 2 when i went king
h7 i thought maybe rook b3 queen e4 and
then
rook beats 2 was was winning but then
um even with with rookie eight
uh with rookie eight there maybe rookie
eight before queen e4
uh yeah i guess rugby two probably wins
there as well
oh no it doesn't oh okay that's that's i
that's why i was not
so sure but yeah i guess queen b5
instead wins uh so i mean i
after i i went king h7 and
obviously a huge part of this was was um
was the trap that he couldn't go queenie
for which i'd which i'd seen
uh but i think if he had defended better
here he would have had some
some chances especially keeping in mind
my game against alareza and in the first
the minus invitational where there was
a kind of similar position where i had
sacrificed an exchange and i had this
beautiful
bishop um on f6 and then queen g6
happened at some point and i was mated
uh so i was really a bit worried that
the
the same thing would happen here but
yeah i had the fantasy of it happening
uh i saw the construction
and then when you play king h7 it's like
flattened ah too bad
but you did get this idea this tactic
magnus we know the rapid portion is
extremely important
winning the rapids generally gives a
great edge
to the players that is that some to the
player who's in the lead is that
something that you're conscious of that
it's important to get these points now
rather than later
i'm just trying to have fun and and play
play well um i feel like when i'm in
decent shape
i generally get a lot of points so i i'm
not too
i'm not too worried about this um i
would say it would have been
would have been even better um with
uh with an extra half half a point
yesterday but uh nevertheless
you know i was i was i was never uh
like particularly worried about my score
i mean um
one and a half out of three or 3 out of
6 that i had yesterday was still
was still fine and
i knew that the pairings were a little
bit easier today
so i took advantage of that
magnus i've never asked you this
question it's a it's a question that
comes up a lot when people ask me
uh but i know you know what happened
with the clippers
and denver yesterday going up 3-1
and blowing big lead after big lead
after big lead
what it what is it that a competitor
does to make sure
that when you're ahead you don't falter
like what's the competitive mindset
that keeps that focus from your world
champion chess perspective
i tell you what it's very very difficult
and
being a front-runner in chess is is
unbelievably hard
i will just say that um
i i think that just applies to
to everybody and it's very easy to play
well when you're you're winning
and um
and you don't have too many scares but
as as soon as you're
you lead uh you lead such a tournament
and
like you lose one important game then
you make a draw then you lose one more
even though
you still might have the lead at that
point it's
very very easy um to
um to to collapse so i would say i still
haven't
still haven't figured it out and i see a
lot of
other guys in in tournaments that um
when they're way up in the standings in
in these rapid blitz events they sort of
sort of freeze so
that's about what i can say um
my best advice is just don't mess up at
any point
and you will be you will be fine but
i i i'm telling you as soon as you start
messing up
it's um it's a slipper slippery slope
we saw that well congratulations on
the best day you could have yes sir yes
absolutely
uh magnus congratulations of course you
started off on a
great footing uh in in the first round
today against lavonna rhony and you just
played this move d5
and lavonne played the move knight d7
you came up with
i think a spectacularly good move bishop
to d3 to b1
uh take us through your thinking at this
point obviously you
you're feeling very good at your
position but if you mess it up
i mean you could have you know
things could easily turn against you so
how did you come
up with the move bishop b1 versus
an alternative well first of all i
i'd missed knight d7 um
but i guess it's it's not the sort of
position where you're
too worried that you're missing anything
because it has to be good
the position just looks too good not to
not to be and yeah after after night
d7 my basic thinking was there must be
something very very good here
and i soon hit upon this idea that
um that i just move the bishop and then
i
i thought putting it on c
uh sorry on uh on uh
b1 would be a little bit more accurate
than putting it on
on c2 so it came it came to me very
quickly but but i think
the engines say that there are a bunch
of good moves like also bishop
to fishbach5 castles this is great
so uh i wouldn't i would not accept too
much race there because anything
anything works but certainly bishop b5
bishop b1 from
an aesthetic point of view is pretty
nice
it really just it it all went so very
swimmingly yeah
this show one line there which was
important
to calculate which was takes uh yeah
taking a five
um taken at five
castles um instead of e6 if it got
knight
c5 then
i probably wouldn't want to go queen b4
because of
the knight jumping to d3
and you know his position has improved
at the very least so i would go queen c2
and this i thought i calculated nicely
so
here goes b4 um and
knight 92
uh and here and here queen takes d5
and so i mean you start calculating rook
d1
but then maybe there's queen e4 and all
is not so clear
so then i started looking at
add knight to g3 then he goes e6
rook d1 um queen c6
and uh i thought there should be some
wind like yeah
rookie for a knight h5 or whatever um
but i thought
if i didn't have to go for it i wouldn't
but um
then instead on move 19 i found
um knight to d4 which is just crushing
after b yeah four ninety four point
sixteen
five nine
yeah no go okay
knight e2 queen takes d5 knights d4
knock knight g3 g3 rip deeper
with d1
what should i do tell me a knight a move
19
not knight g3 what should i do
1990 1994
yes and then e6 root d1 and
knight f5 cannot be prevented got it
okay very nice
you're a patient man magnus you see what
i have to deal with magnus
you have to deal with hey that's it
magnus again congratulations 3-0
very very impressive as you uh bounce
back
uh very well done jen um any questions
great congratulations great great
comeback from day one
and it was it was always so great to
watch our games today they were very
exciting
congrats magnus see you tomorrow see you
tomorrow
and here is how he's done so far
everybody
does a lot well we call that disconnect
version
who you know that game most likely would
have been a draw
but uh other than that just a phenomenal
performance
with the three wins today including that
uh
that gorgeous uh second round game
against lanier with the uh
we'll take this youtube check tactic
which i find like really
uh instructive the way he talked about
how he had planned that with king h7
because a lot of times kids will look at
the tactic that doesn't work
and they'll be like well that was a
waste of time and it's like no it's not
a waste of time a few months later
suddenly he he pounces because he sees
it instantly he already analyzed it
it re-occurs and i think
there's another special guest uh is that
right jeffrey johnson
in the house yeah welcome guys yes
hi jeffrey hi welcome welcome
indeed i
i thought i heard him but i'm not
hearing him clearly say
hello again jeff can you uh can you hear
me now yes
yes we can we can congratulations
on uh how you've done so far you had a
big win today
tell us your feelings about playing in
the event we didn't get a chance to
speak to you yesterday
oh yeah obviously i'm very happy to get
this opportunity
it's always been a dream of mine to
compete in the
grand chess tour so to receive this
really hoping
to make the best of it and learn a lot
from
playing these top top guys now your win
today
was really nice uh
the one against nepo that that was sweet
now you you took a lot of time at the
point with your knight on c2
and it looked like you were looking for
the kill was that what was going on
because finally you decided you know
what let me just back out and take this
bishop because there's king k and castle
but what was taking you so long at this
point
yeah actually i was a bit frustrated uh
because
i was sure that bishop c4 has to work
somehow
when i mean his king is uh all the way
up the board and i have queen knight
bishop
and potentially my two rooks can come in
but i didn't actually
figure out how to do it during the game
so
i started looking for maybe more um more
cleaner ways i guess to you know just
pick up restore the material and then i
should have decisive attack so that's
what i ended up going for
not every day you beat a world-class
player in 21 moves
with the black pieces that must have
felt sweet
yeah well i i think it was certainly a
gift from nepo
because okay i played the alakins
defense just hoping
to get a game not imagining anything
like this but
basically i think he he wanted to punish
me so
he decided to take on b7 because it's
probably the only way he can
hope for an advantage and unfortunately
for him it's just
busted after uh after knight d before
cool well congrats i have one topic that
i'm going to indulge myself
in and my basketball fandom with i know
uh the question is
does mike d'antoni stay or does he go
uh i think a lot of coaches in the
offseason are
gonna have to go um
uh and probably he's one of them so
yeah i bring for those of you
internationally who don't know what i'm
talking about mike d'antoni's the coach
of the basketball team
the houston rockets uh they were bumped
from the playoffs and i know that
jeffrey's
living in houston is a big basketball
fan we've talked about this before
so you think he's got to go and uh what
about your tandem of
west brook westbrook and hardin are they
going to stay together
well well i have to correct one thing uh
i'm actually from dallas so i'm
i'm a mavericks fan i'm a big leader not
rockets
yeah but i still have i still have an
opinion on on the rocket
gotcha gotcha all right you the luca
dances crowd i don't know
okay i mix that up you good news
everyone you're gonna have a lot more
chances to see maurice and jeffrey talk
basketball because jeffrey we're gonna
see you
not only in this event but in two events
in october
a lot of the times you have conflicts
with the us junior closed but this year
you're going to be the top seed in that
in that event right yeah yeah i'm
looking forward to it
and then of course you're also going to
be playing in the u.s championship as
well
um any i have a question about this uh
this time of lockdown have you picked up
any
um you know new hobbies or interests
considering that like everybody's
lifestyle changed so much
uh to be honest not really uh generally
for me it's just
it's chess and it's sports so i can
still been able to to do those things i
haven't really
dabbled in some other and other things
well it's great to have you um and we're
excited that we're going to be able to
call so many of your excited games
this summer um yeah is anything else to
ask
no just uh congratulations a miniature
against jan
was really nice and i i'm with you 100
percent
uh jeffrey that i think bishop c4 queen
d3
check had to be winning like you
all all of us we were frustrated because
we didn't see the knockout blow
and we thought that you made a really
really good practical choice
with rook b6 and knight take c6 as you
did and you played queen d5 and won
prosaically
uh sometimes when you don't see the win
you got to give it a rest but
a a really really nice victory uh well
done
well it turned out well yes though
because then there was a synchronicity
with magnus carlsen's win and rook takes
b2
so it all worked out in the end it's
certainly good job
good job jx we'll see you tomorrow all
right see you thanks
jx from dallas cool young man cool young
man
got a variety of interests well at least
sports interest
that is i know he's a big sports fan and
and practitioner as well
he is got a ways to go but you do notice
that he's tied with grishchik and
nakamura
not bad company to keep he's certainly
not at the bottom of the scoring table
soros table but
who's at the top well we can see it's
one magnus carlsen who
got a bunch of twos there two two two
that's two points
for every victory he had today nobody
else could possibly
replicate that accomplishment that's
right he brought out the broom
did um a magnus carlson today and
nakamura's face
you look this is the pain face of a man
who just did not find his a game today
as i believe this is from his game with
nepo uh
the end that was the queen versus the
two rooks game
where we thought the queen he was going
to put up some
better resistance than what he did and
he ended up getting outplayed and losing
i thought at first that we were having
an interview with him and i was like no
that's a replay he doesn't look that
upset when he has to
sit through an interview with us just a
little bit upset not really upset
he's got to find his rhythm he has not
found it so far in this event he lost on
the first day
where i first round right away to magnus
and that big pairing
and to lose again he you know he was
you can't afford to lose again basically
just right you just can't yeah
and he's just hasn't found that
scintillating form that
is typical for him but tomorrow he'll
have another chance
and then the blitz close it out you all
know is nakamura's bread and butter i
mean the best thing for
for him is if we could add a third
column bullet chest
right indeed then he's gonna plenty of
time
the problem jen is that rapid is two
points each
so round seven through nine there's six
big points up for grabs
magnus took all of his six today naca
has to look to
keep the pace he cannot let magnus
keep running it up he's nothing to do
about it right now because he's four
points behind him
with these three rounds to go he's got a
hope that magnus has a hiccup
and the other players as well so that he
just can close the gap
just a little maybe down to two points
if he gets it down to two he has a
chance
it's at four don't mess it up
don't mess it up that's right but it's
this has been an amazing day it's gone
by so fast um so
many great games i i can't wait till
tomorrow tomorrow we are going to close
out the rapid portion
of the saint louis rapid and blitz and
it's going to start again
at 12 50 that's st louis time
um yes maurice see you same time
same place tomorrow absolutely jen
maurice has been a
pleasure thank you everyone for sharing
your day with us
join tomorrow and tell your friends
where you're hanging out
good night thanks for watching
so
you